Well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
You should see me when
we drive by a bike store.
You should see me when we
drive by a bike store. Bye Bye.
Bye Bye.
There you go. That was cool. It was
called stranger bikes and it's by,
uh, let's see. Snick and Steven
Snick and Steven. But it says,
I like that. There you go. You
know, I like, I really like that.
Stranger bikes playing off
of the stranger things theme.
I can't wait for that show to come back.
It's coming back dude.
When now I guess there's
a big uproar right now.
People are upset that they didn't renew
since eight. Oh, I couldn't get into that.
I tried and I couldn't.
Did you try? Uh, I don't.
I saw the pilot. That's the only thing
I saw. I couldn't give it. Yeah, I,
and they do it. Can I tell you we was a
bunch of people all over the world, right?
The different paths.
Superpowers,
like one guy can come a lot and then the
other lady miss that episode entirely.
He didn't know that. Nope. And
they all go on to come strike. No,
I think you're confusing
that with something else.
One of them can talk to Hitler.
No, no, no. I don't think so. Hmm.
I don't think that can happen.
We tried watching last. Rob,
is that what you guys, did you do your
exercise this weekend while I was away?
Yeah, I did. I worked on it.
How many did you get through?
I got through 50, but that's
getting, that's progress.
Your first 50 strokes,
you'd get 300 strokes and,
and then possible have an orgasm.
Just not ejaculate.
Orgasm happened on the inside. How
do you, I hear that happens when you,
when you get snipped, Rob, Rob, rob
that you, the beginning. I
don't think you forgot anything.
When you get snipped, when you get
a vasectomy. Oh, that you might not,
I don't think you make a buck in the
beginning and then you make something. No,
doctor drew was saying that he doesn't
have any juice that comes out cause he
had, uh, he had, he had a, his
testicle cancer. Sorry. None
of us like to me. Oh yeah.
Yeah. Because I mean, you still have seen
it, but not the potent load. Yeah. Yeah.
No sperm they'd know per minute sperms.
Perms.
Perms like shrimps. Yeah.
Sperms. Sperms. Yes.
People do miss pluralize
that sperms shrimps a lot.
I hate that. Especially if
they just had an espresso. Oh,
I gave that or they just
came from the library.
The Espresso one makes me the
most upset cause I hear uh,
servers and Baristas.
Yeah. And they're like,
and you want an ex extra shot of espresso
in that? Yeah. How do you work here?
You should know. And you've read
it on the menu and overheard. Yeah.
Stupid fuck sperms sperms.
Um,
so it was a, Oh, so we,
we tried watching yesterday
after porn ends to hoping,
yeah.
To find, oh, oh, oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
Hoping to find some gems in there like
we did with the other porno documentary.
Yeah. Where is, she was like, she did
that hooker math section, a segment.
And remember that was the best to a dye.
I remember the math. Go ahead and math.
We're not good at math. The math,
the hooker math was you get like,
I dunno, $500 to shoot a scene. Right.
Going over it. She was like, yeah,
but they offer you to let
a guy come inside of you.
Yeah. And internal surprise. Uh,
an extra hundred dollars. Right. She goes,
so you get an extra hundred bucks.
He comes inside then, you know, uh,
the morning after pill, the plan B,
it was only $40 $40. So that's 60
bucks I got to keep in my pocket.
It's a win win is all I gotta do
is let this, it, I don't know,
common me on camera. So that's
neat. It's immortalized forever.
What's wrong with that? But you
get extra 60 to 60 bucks. Huh?
Like I was telling you if
it, if, if she had been like,
and then for like a guy to finish inside
and I get another $400, we were like,
well, you know, that's, that makes
sense. Okay. That makes sense.
$400 would be worth a guy doing that
just to show you like what scumbags the
like that industry is run by.
They don't even go like here's
140 so the 40 you get the plan B,
you get getting make $100.
They're like, you figure it out,
whatever. You got it done. You maybe you
want the kid who knows so don't you. Yeah.
Jesus. So we were looking for some
gems, but apparently these porn stars,
they followed or too smart and they
figured out how they were going.
I think we got to keep on,
I think we should finish it because
if you notice they would to uplifting
for me.
Well they would go,
they would go different types of
stories like up and down. Right.
So like they would do one person who
was like, that was biased back then.
And now I'm having, you know,
I'm retired and, and yeah,
and then so like that's a kind of a
sweeter story. Then you go to the,
the guys that I have aids and you're like,
oh shit.
And then they go to the lady who was like,
I had a lot of fun doing it and you
know, I was crazy, blah blah blah.
So I think we should, I think if we keep
watching, we're going to get somewhere.
Yeah. You know, maybe fun. But it
definitely wasn't hooker. Hilarious.
Yeah. Give me those hard knocks stories.
I know his was like, man, his HIV story,
you're like Jesus.
Well to his credit he looks great.
Like he really seems to
maintain his body well and,
and he's working out a lot
and he seems happy. Oh my God,
God that dude is like so extra yoked.
But I think you gotta be juicing right
to be on that. Have that body. Yes.
Especially with an auto immune disease.
Definitely.
My Dad was telling me about that.
Um,
about some of these
bodies you see on people.
So like if you don't know top dog who's
obviously been on this show a million
times,
he was a competitive
Olympic lifter for years.
I mean from the time he was 13 till about
29 or 30 and he would working out six
days a week, most of his workouts
were like three hours plus.
Like these guys were maniacs. And he
goes, you know, I was in great shape.
I was a two time state champion.
I was ranked nationally. He goes,
I didn't have like the body that you
see some of these guys have. Oh Wow.
Somebody who is lifting every
everyday and eating steak every day.
They can potatoes every day,
every day.
This was before supplements or vitamins?
No roids he's just like I work
out, I eat a steak. Yeah. Data.
And that was what he did.
But it's interesting because you see
these days you see crazy bodies soap,
especially in men like
super, um, sculpted,
you know statuesque bodies and,
but it's also the era of like people
taking growth hormone and and uh,
and test out, you know
like sure. Access. Yeah,
access all these things
because what with him,
like I've seen pictures of him and his
and his is like super competitive lifting
days.
It looks like a super fit guy,
but you don't see like
muscles kind of and a falling
down really defined and
the veins and all that.
You and your dad are built
like brick shit house is,
I say sure. Yeah. Not a shit brick
house. I always get it confused.
You do say that a lot of the,
but you guys are built for a,
that you're very sturdy and Ellis has
that back to you guys have brought the
shoulders and the back for it.
We have the same blueprint.
My Dad just took it in the direction
of working hard at it. Yeah,
right. Yeah. But your genetic, I mean you
lift weights. We've got way too. Yeah.
You Know Jim, whatever. No, I
could, I could pursue it more heat.
But like we were talking about his
workouts one time and I was like,
fuck that dude. I mean he was competitive.
That's different. I mean I wouldn't,
I don't have the desire to do what he
was doing and I both have that lazy gene
counteracts any sort of wanting.
I forced myself to swim and do pilates,
but I hate it.
He also had a group,
this is the thing that they would lift
a as like a team and he goes like if you
left early or skipped any day,
um,
the other guys would ride you so hard
about it that you were like, fuck that.
Like they would only go on dates after,
you know what I mean? So if it was like,
Hey, I'll pick you up on Friday and
you go like seven, I'd be like, no,
nine 30 after I'm done. Yeah.
When I'm done. Listen. Wow.
So they were so into it.
That's cool though.
It's good fucking 30 sets of squats,
like not to you,
but your dad is the type of personality
who really likes structure and
discipline and focus and like having that,
you know what I found a unrelated to
this really interesting watching that
documentary was like,
she was an old lady now,
but she did like the devil and Mrs. Jones
or whatever that porno is the old ass
one, by the way. She looked fucking
old.
Oh,
she liked the Rob Rob Guy.
But uh,
so they showed them a picture of her
nude and I was startled by it because
you're like, oh yeah, that's what
human bodies looked like prior. Nice,
normal bottom.
And it was beautiful.
But I forget what normal
bodies look like in print.
Human bodies with natural
breasts that just,
that that laid normal and
they weren't enormous.
Quadruple d fuck my
triple d slept wife tits.
I know in platinum blonde please,
please, please, please, please send out
face. It looks like it's drawn on
like she's in like she's in shock,
the photos and eyebrows and wonder what
the aesthetic is the pop like how did
that, how like looking at different
looking women obviously, you know like
variety. Yeah. And it's exciting to
see, you know, but like hungry. Why did,
why it went to like,
as like that's hot cause
I don't feel like that is,
I don't know which committee decided that
all porn chicks have to look identical
because I mean like there are men who
like hungry or tits and begged shots and
different shape faces are interesting.
Different noses, different, you know,
all that Shit is interesting.
I know what I think it isn't hair.
I think the beginning was Pam Anderson.
Honestly, I think sometime around her era.
You're right. People went, oh, the
gold standard is blonde is fuck.
Huge tits. Tiny, tiny waist and Barbie.
It's essentially Barbie.
Even actually know the porn stars body.
Is it bigger tits than my Barbie
had Barbie was like a c sure.
These pages or quadruple t g tits,
super coachable to slot dean
like we haven't even started with what
do it look how many interesting topics
we've already gotten. Me and we were ready
to be a good show. I mean high ticket.
Yeah, let's do it. Let's do the show.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's it go.
Hey Dude, your fucking
camera outta here. Fresh.
None of your fucking business.
You talk by trespass.
You get the fuck Outta here now.
Okay,
Judah here now don't fuck with me.
Partner.
You're not in the PR staff are you? You
don't fucking worry about who I'm with.
Oh was Randy. Don't bring in one. Loving
to live. No. Borrowing the fungus.
Well,
welcome.
We'll go to your mom's
house with tone circle.
Christina pushes.
It's interesting.
Okay,
what's your cock bite?
Hey cart bite.
You're not part of the ta staff
or yeah, no, he's not PR staff.
Pr. Public Relations. You're
not part of the transsexual. Oh,
adjustments staff. Are
you a ta? Transgendered?
What's your end Pronoun? Brona
down. Sorry. Ended. Are you?
Hold on. Yeah. You didn't even, you
just assumed my pronoun. That's true.
I did really assume it.
When are we going to see non-binary porn?
I can't wait to see all that
stuff. The only, that's kind of,
of course that's coming. Of course
it's coming. What's Your Pronoun?
I was on Instagram. You know, I love
Instagram. Instagram is my favorite.
Silver isn't it? The best is I
like photos. I like, you know,
looking at a photo and deciding like,
that's enough information for me.
It's enough. I like a nice
caption of photo. I'm done.
I like it because you really get insight
into people's mental illness. It's not,
you know, one thing I saw, the
cursory that I realized is,
is fucking super weird to me.
Hmm. Not Weird. It's just I go,
hmm. Hmm. Well, I love cars.
I've always been in love with
cars since I was little boy.
I like playing with toy cars or like
car magazines. I just love cars. Yeah.
But you'll find somebody that has,
you know,
a photo like let's say a phone, oh,
this guy in front of his car. I'm like,
I was beautiful car,
go to his page and his page
is nothing but him and his cars.
And you're like,
it's, it's just like, it's too much. Yeah.
And it's also like this guy defines
himself entirely by what he has.
That's interesting. You know,
there's that. That's, so
that's how the guys do it.
Yeah. Now the girls do the
body, the girls do the, well,
what's interesting about the body thing
is that they take half naked pictures.
What?
Oh my God, what I got to show
you? I just got this text. What?
The bottom read the bottom.
Oh. Oh my God. Tonight.
Oh my God. What do I do? Uh, I dunno.
We'll have to figure this out. Should
we press pause? I think so. Shit.
All right. Got some exciting show business
news for Tom, which we can't reveal.
Yeah. Well, I mean, yeah, I didn't
mean to be so dramatic. Obviously.
You are basically, um, it's,
it's, I mean, I can say this,
it's just like I had an audition
and they want to see me again,
so it's next level. So that's awesome. And
it's very exciting. And will everybody,
everybody cross your sphincters
for Tommy caused crusher be holes,
so it's all good. Yeah. Big Excitement.
Good. Good week for the Sigora House.
Not going on. Yeah. What were we
talking about before the surprise? Um,
Fudge Oh, scamper. Snapples
well,
where are we talking about?
We're talking about while we were talking
about the porno thing before the break
bodies bodies. Um, and then
I played this fucking guy.
So do you want to know what
that setup was for that,
why that guy was flipping out? Yeah,
so apparently there was this, uh,
this is,
okay.
I'll tell you what the thing
said here is that the guy there,
there was a,
an incident occurred at the International
Longshore Warehouse Union in Longview,
Washington.
And reporters were there to ask about
a hostage situation that happened weeks
prior. So six guards were held
hostage for a couple hours,
um,
after 500 or more long shore men broke
down gates and smash windows in the guard
shack. And this long shoreman is in
no mood to answer these questions.
So in other words,
this is something that's been like in
the news and this and this news reporter
is just like, Hey, I want
to ask again. You know,
or ask more about the
incident that happened.
I ain't called him macaque bite,
which is really funny.
I've never heard that one before. Right.
It is amazing. Talk by, that's a great,
yeah. Wow. I love it. You
had that isolated already.
You knew that was a winner.
Yeah. Cock bike. Yeah. So this is a shark
bite. This is how the whole thing unfolds.
This is the guy showing up,
the news guy going like,
oh, hi, I'm with you.
And just wanted to know if there was
anyone here want to talk to us about the
situation from where actually you
can go down and fill out talking to
egg. They'll tell you how they're
fucking the longshoreman around here.
That's the gentleman who gets more
upset and then I guess you see that the
camera man,
one of them starts filming something
printed out.
Hey,
none of your fucking business you cocked,
bite miss you a trespass.
You get the fuck out of here now.
Get outta here.
Don't fuck with me partner.
You're not the PR staff. You,
I liked it.
That guy maintained his sense of humor.
I also think it's funny that the guy goes,
unless you want trespassing,
like not if you want to be
charged with trespassing,
like unless you want robbery.
Right. He's just, he's,
he missed conjugated is under stress,
under stress and it's understandable,
but I think he keeps saying it.
You want trespassing?
Like you want something to drink,
wasn't trespassing on with you.
Trespassing.
He might be drunk.
Jammer broke you cock sucker.
Just wanted to hear your by now or
you're going to get trespassing.
You know you're going to get trespassing.
You're going to get charged with
trust or you know, I'm, I'm an,
I'm going to say you are
trespassing or you are trespassing.
Trespassing is what you said.
You're going to get it.
You're going to get are going to
give it to him. They're trespassing.
You're going to give you a shot
of trespassing. The shrimps. Yeah,
the shrimps and the ESPRESSOS.
All the shrimps.
The sperms and the expressors are
going to get you're trespassing and the
library.
The library.
You guys have a library here
doing a paper on the shrimp.
Oh,
we were leaving.
Do you know what you dumb mother fucker.
You like, you're fucking glasses.
Don't fucking threaten me.
You son of a bitch.
Get the fuck out of this parking lot.
Right?
Get outta here.
Now
why is this guy fucking with
him? I liked the, uh, he has.
Here's a great disposition though,
Cameron. At least he's like,
I'm just doing this man. He's
done this a 500 times. Yeah,
he's seen people lose
their mind. Like, I don't,
you don't get to hear people
yell like this anymore. You know,
you don't really get to see it.
Cock bites and stuff.
I feel like I haven't seen people
freak out like this in a minute. Yeah.
I miss it. We just pull
these all the time. People.
That's exciting to me because I like
seeing people get upset like that.
Especially if we're funny.
You know this guy is,
he's upset because there is a buildup
of people asking this that you don't get
to see. In other words, usually
when someone loses their mind,
it's not over something
reasonable. Right. It's,
it's because something
builds up over time.
This guy has been asked these questions
for six weeks. Original trigger. Yes.
And he's mad at you. I'm mad at this
guy. He's mad at the fucking man.
The first for a second hundred reporters
that came. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is pretty good.
It's so funny,
Texas.
I'm not going to touch that cock sucker.
I fucking cold cocked him in a heartbeat.
Why? Get out of the fucking parking lot?
Fuck you. You Cock sucker. That's
why name fuck you talk soccer.
Okay.
Yeah, I did get him down. That's his
name. Fuck you. That's fine. Fuck you.
Cock sucker. That's my name. I miss the
shit. Yeah, we gotta get more angry clubs.
Again,
I forgot how fun these are.
And if we could go around the room
and everybody just state your name.
Yeah.
Your Cock sucker.
Right. Hi. Fuck you.
You cogs are good. Talk,
bite bite.
And I missed the racist ones.
Remember when he's like you
fucking Spec. I'm sorry. Huh. Huh?
Screaming over the fence.
That was again, one was great.
I wonder if this sock my pussy.
That was good.
We been while that guy was
um, our kiss my pussy. Yeah.
Not Suck my policy that no
mother
these long shoreman though.
I wouldn't fuck with these
guys. Well, you know,
are these guys do real work for real,
real fucking men?
Oh, our old landlord, uh,
one of our past landlords was
a longshoreman and he was not,
he was a very gentle, sweet guy, but he
would tell stories of his, uh, you know,
yeah. Coworkers be a gnarly dudes. Yeah.
So my real gnarly, real gnarly. Where,
why worser shit. Just got, why water? Uh,
I was at the Arrow Puerto
yesterday, bright and early and, um,
I was listening to people talk on their
phones and the rage inside of me is kind
of like that, like the cock
bite. Yeah. Rage where you're
like, what are you doing,
asshole. You know? And
especially in this era,
people feel okay about watching videos
on their phone at full volume in public,
like who's,
and nobody's correcting this behavior,
but the phone conversations insidious
because you're on the receiving end of one
side of a conversation.
Yeah.
And I think when it's way worser is
when it's in a foreign language. Yeah.
And now I, I don't even understand
what the fuck you're saying.
And your language sounds horrible to me.
And is it,
I think the worst language,
I don't know what he was,
it may have been Vietnamese only because
they don't have a volume control.
I know. It's so loud. It's on like, dude,
you know that you're in public.
Yeah. Why are you fucking,
it's it's and yelling in your
language and it's, listen,
we spoke Hungarian growing up in
my house, but you know what? Yeah.
What was that speakerphone feedback?
What we didn't do in public, you speak
Hungarian because it's rude and it's,
it excludes people. Yeah.
You know what I mean?
You speak fucking English when
we were public asshole. The, the,
the speaking in another language in
public because you really have a secret to
excluding. Yeah. Yes. It's
disrespectful to the, you know,
I see this shit all the time where
people hold the phone in front of them.
They're like, stop it right
here. Right now. Stop it. Yeah.
Go on at the airport. Yeah. Stop it. Yeah.
Yeah, I know. And you're like, dude,
like no one wants to hear this whole
fucking thing. It's never about, you know,
it's not, it's not about who won the Nobel
prize or uh, you know, quantum theory.
It's always like, we're going to meet
you down at the baggage claim. All right.
Yeah. Okay. Well, Susan gun to bring the
cake. Yeah. She's going to bring the cake.
Like what are you doing? It's total
like it is that some people have,
um,
total disregard for the world
around them and for other people.
I don't even know if the book,
I think some of it is conscious.
I think it is conscious. Like they want
you to hear what they're talking about.
Sometimes feel like it's a something,
you know,
it's like
I important
you're standing there and you're like,
Yep,
interesting.
None of us are sitting here minding our
own business because that's the thing
that stands out is that everyone,
literally everyone else
in those situations is
considerate of everyone else.
That's why that person stands out.
You're the only one doing, doesn't care.
Okay. What's your least favorite
language though? Let's get into that.
I'm going to go with, I don't like
Russian. I have a bias though.
We all have biases.
Don't we can say is that I don't like
rushing because culturally that's my tribe
ish. There are cousins. Uh,
so that hard sounding eastern bloc shit.
Yeah.
My shoulders go up around my
years and never said, by the way,
as someone who has no connection,
it doesn't sound good to me.
I don't like your brushes.
Yeah.
I like hearing, I had to pick like, I
don't mind hearing the romance languages.
It just sounds soft, Freddie.
I mean Portuguese. Yeah.
Those are all like, when do you
get to hear Portuguese? And Paul,
I seldom get you hear that.
But I'm saying like it's not,
but when you hear like homicide
it, I'm a halogen, Amazon,
any language
Israeli,
go back to your fucking country
regardless. Regardless. I'm
saying I don't give a shit.
I'm not talking specific cultures.
Don't care.
Drawful language. What's
bothersome? Doesn't sound beautiful.
I'm not at all just nice. That's
not, is it terrible? Yeah. But uh,
but I, I need to, yes.
I know that somebody's
Farsi speaking English.
Like that is why it works.
Or two awful, awful. Yeah.
We're going to get,
now that they're at the market,
there's no onions and
you're like, Jesus, dude,
it's worse than you can't understand it
cause you're like your conversations so
dumb. Yeah. God, it's so boring.
People would just repeat the same things
to each other over and over. It is,
there is a split.
There are people that are oblivious
because you can look at someone with the
fuck are you doing here?
They're like, I don't know.
And then there's people that
it's a what it is. It's,
it's a an attempt to show power.
Yeah,
because what you're saying is like,
yeah, this is a moment where I can,
I'm going to talk loudly in this room,
dominating the space with my voice.
You assholes have to hear when I'm
talking about why time you and I were at a
hotel,
we were coming out of a nice restaurant
and there was some guy on his speaker
phone, I don't know if you remember
it, but we were getting a valet.
We're waiting for the valet
and full, full volume, like
from like sounding like Ivory
Coast something and saw all,
I mean actually I enjoyed him
because I liked that accent, but the,
it was just, he was so
loud. Yeah. It's so,
it's just so deep and when you're tired
and you're in the airport, you're like,
I don't want to, I don't want to hear your
fucking, I don't want to hear you bro.
I agree a lot of,
ah,
basically I don't want to hear your
conversation period or your video or the
music.
The worst.
One time I was sitting next to a
girl watching Korean soap operas.
Here's how a Christ loud some people are
as I'm on a plane a week ago and a kid
has his iPad or whatever, or
some toy, boop, boop, boop,
boop, boop, boop. And I'm like,
hey. And I look over and then his parent
was like, Oh, don't forget that one.
Like it was helping him be shit
again. Yeah. And you're like,
why don't you tell your kid to turn that
down or lunch? Give them headphones.
So headphones, the rest of us
don't have to hear PPP. PPP,
it's obnoxious.
You are obnoxious.
One time I was on a plane and
a guy was watching his movie,
but he had his earbuds and,
but the volume was pumping out full,
full volume and it was a late night
flight. And I'm eyeballing him,
eyeballing and finally I go,
excuse me,
could you listen to that on your ear
phones? And he goes, oh, I thought I was,
I'm so sorry. And He, and
then he plugged it in.
That was the one time I did actually see
a person last week do the same thing.
Right.
I didn't correct him,
but what happened was a couple of
sitting next to each other and star wars
started. You can hear it in
the cabin like Dun, Dun, Dun,
and I see them going out with
their headphones and they're like,
and then, and then all of a sudden
the guy goes, we're not plugged in.
I plugged it in, but that was,
it's funny. Different, right?
Like he's trying to civilized human
people are fucking psychos though.
It's it. It really is to the advent
of the, the cellular phone. Yeah,
it's the iPhone etiquette.
We really haven't,
we haven't figured out yet what
proper etiquette is for the phone.
I think that'll be, hopefully in
the next few years, people go,
all right at dinner.
It shouldn't be on the fucking table.
There should be an iPhone
etiquette school or,
or just societal norms that we should
all adhere to from now on. Agreed.
Or it's my first order of visiting
anything now, by the way. Oh boy.
Not going to answer that. That's
a set up. Of course it is. No,
it isn't. I'm reading a
book right now. Red Notice,
what does that red notice?
Is there a lot of pictures in there?
Zinged you just reading it
interesting. Uh Huh. What's that about?
It's about this guy who has his
grandfather started the communist party.
Oh cool.
And then he went on.
It's a Russian basically
real life thriller.
So it's my enemy basically.
Yeah.
But as an entire spiel about the Russians.
So I'm in the part
right now where he's um,
it was basically introducing how he
came to work. He's a businessman,
but in eastern Europe. Oh, very cool. So
I didn't know you were interested in that.
You should talk to my dad about that.
He loves Connie and this stuff,
but you're not reading anything right now.
Okay.
Course. I read stuff all the time. But
what are you reading right now? Uh,
it's called the, the something
of the gifted child. The,
it's called the something
of the gifted child. Yeah.
I read a child psychology books,
so I don't fuck up our kid.
The drama of the gifted child. This lady
has a review of that right here. Okay,
here we go.
I was reading it.
Hmm?
Oh Shit.
She's not even talking yet.
That was my mistake. Okay, here
we go. It's reading the book.
Yeah. Footage of me
reading. I read kindles.
I don't read that.
Mike
is like a monster.
Pretty good review, right? Um, is that
what the dream? That's the same thing.
Do we get fart Mr Com?
I think we did last week.
I think we need to start
doing something with it.
I'm surprised nobody had fart
mistress. I know. I'm really well,
it just goes to show that the women doing
the fart videos aren't that creative
and that I could really put
a dent in that industry.
Really sell that to somebody.
You know. Fart mistress.
I mean to a real fart
mistress. I would love to. Hey,
anyone out there want fart mistress?
This one owns it.
I'll sell it to you
for a reasonable price.
That's a long foof.
Whoa. That was a really
good one. Really crazy.
That's almost ass rapper.
That's how my mother spoke English
when she first got to this country.
It's like she would call a fan of monster.
I remember that little months took me,
cause she didn't know how to say fan
like monsters make noise with this lady
said that her ass is like a monster. It's
pretty neat and it's kind of accurate.
I didn't, you have quite a uh, Brown
day. I'm so glad you brought that up.
You may want to hit the all board
brown. Oh really? Oh okay. All right.
He didn't know that was coming.
Hold on.
So I went to a man friend
disco this weekend.
Thank you everybody that came out
to my shows. They were super fun.
It was really great.
I had a lot of fun,
met a lot of mommies and so anyways,
on Saturday I go have Thai food by my
hotel on the Embarcadero there and I don't
eat fucking honkie food. You know
what I'm saying? When I want flavor,
I guess some God damn flavor
will supposedly San Francisco.
I mean you have so many great choices in
San Francisco to head to like eat real
authentic. Yeah. That loves the food
there. So I go to this Thai place,
I ordered my Panang curry and I was like,
you make that shit spicy and don't
make it fucking white girl spicy.
Like I want legit heat on that bitch.
I actually have a bit in my act
right now about that is a seriously,
seriously, is it because I ordered that
way at Korean barbecue so much? No, no.
I demand that they give me spicy
sooner. They'll go, oh, okay.
Any hurdles?
I order it and I ask for spicy and
they bring it out and I'm like,
Oh shit. Like they
really, it was too much,
but I couldn't send it back because
I demanded it, you know what I mean?
So I had to eat the dish anyways
and push through the pain.
It was hot as fuck dude. They,
they didn't hold back on me at all.
So like I have to do this, like I
can't, I have to save face. So I eat it,
I forget about it,
I'm fine.
And then showtime rolls round and the
farts begin and I'd forgotten what I'd
eaten earlier. I was like,
why are these farts here?
You know when you do that where
you kind of are like, I'm farting,
but I'm not sure why.
And then it occurred to me,
I had that Thai food and
it was like mystery solved.
So I sit down to make brown
and I'm having so many paint,
it's so much pain because
the farts are really violent,
like hard farts and I fucking,
I'm shitting,
I'm shitting and it's showtime.
Now I'm getting,
I'm getting text messages
from the club like, Hey,
the show's at seven 30 you know that
right? And I'm in my show outfit,
like tights dress and I'm like,
I'm shitting and it's bad and it's like
a multi wiper and I don't have time to
go shit to shower because it's showtime.
Like I've,
I just had to keep, rub, rub, rub, wipe,
wipe, wipe, wipe, neverending wipe.
There's, I've leaky. But there's
so much toilet paper in the bowl,
there's so much brown in the bull.
It was so painful. So I flush
and,
and I'm like call it went
down and then the water rises,
did the, the, the
starts to spill a little, little, little.
And then miraculously it
slowly goes back down.
So it goes under when you told me that
turns on the ground reminded me
of Jacksonville. That's right.
That's where tourists were on the comedy
zone and that's where I had turns on
the ground and I had to tell the hotel
staff that there were two on. Yeah.
Classic.
My Jam right there
on the ground.
I heard you on the ground
Simpler made that.
That was really good.
So I got really close to
tourists on the ground,
but no turrets on the ground in San
Francisco. But it was close. Dude.
Tariff is bad and I didn't,
like I said,
it was just like a leaky but situation
all night I kept wiping. It was terrible.
Yeah. Do you get that too? I forget
what the never ending wipe were like.
You just keep wiping almost god.
It's so upsetting.
You know that brings up, this actually
came in, you brought this up right now.
This isn't planned.
Look, this email came in.
I swear to God.
How do blind people know to stop wiping?
Hey Hitler's. I've been a big fan of,
so this is mommy.
Tina was in Fart next a few months ago.
I've been binge listening
you 40 plus hours a week
having every second of it.
I'm not all the way through,
but I've always wanted to know one thing.
I believe you're the people that helped
me find out how do blind people know
when to stop wiping. How have we gone
this long without knowing this age?
Old Question.
Thank you for everything you do.
Look forward to the next
time you are in Fart. Nixon.
This is the funniest thing
we've never discussed.
I feel like we may have discussed it.
Feels familiar.
I really do think we'd discuss it but
I think it's been a long time. They,
I asked one time they wipe a bunch and
then they do a bare hand wipe and they
smelled it.
They have a dog do it.
Seeing eye dog. No, no, no.
It's a reasonable question I think.
I think the dog sniffs or be home.
I think it was brown. I think you know,
I think you just get a sense of it.
Just like a a feel because you're so,
you're so tied to your vision
and helping you eventually.
Like I think what happens is it becomes
intuitive and they just go, I'm done. Now.
It's a good theory. Well, if you're blind,
I guess have someone write in for for
you or you could write in how do they do
it? They don't think they can take, right
either. They don't type on an email.
Sure they do. Are they have
Braille keyboard type? You
use your Braille keyboard.
Yeah.
Let us know.
Let us know how you got all
these mysteries and tell us
about the learning curve.
Tell us about bad times. You guessed
wrong. Don't just be like, yeah,
of course I know how to do it and tell us.
Give us a little insight.
This is so important.
The work we're doing on your mom's house,
like when I asked if we're trying to,
people knew they're retarded and now
we're going to find out if blind people
know how they're done wiping.
That's pretty influencing.
We're really helping society.
We are helping a lot.
We haven't yet mentioned that.
Pretty soon we're going to
be joined by a guest today.
Mr Aristotle Schaefer is coming
in really short for Aristotle,
not his name. Definitely not.
No, I wasn't Jewish. No, no.
It's a Greek name. I
know that. Um Oh wait,
I feel like I have more thoughts on
this blind wiping situation though.
Uh, yeah. Okay. Do you have
any more opinions on it?
Are you saying that thinking about it,
I feel like that's a wild okay.
Oh here's what I was gonna say.
Cause sometimes browns are misleading.
Like the other week I had what I thought
would be a disastrous cleanup. Yeah.
I think it was hot and I was like,
oh this is going to be a nightmare.
And I went to wipe and the paper
was totally clean. Yeah, it's not,
it's just not a, a shirt,
a science, you know? Yeah.
Are you texting airy? What's he doing?
Just letting them know one time.
I don't know. I hate when people
are late. Let me to, Oh God,
I just fuck you know what? I thought it
was funny as an man friend disco that uh,
the women were talking about,
cause when I lived there in the 90s,
it was hard to find a boyfriend
cause all the dudes are gay now.
Now they're not now.
They're not all gay now they're all nerds.
I here because of the tech industry
moving up there that there's a lot more
straight guys,
but that they're all socially not adapt.
So they're all dorks. Big
Old dorks. Yeah. You're,
the whole tech industry has moved into
that area. It's completely changes.
It's also priced out basically the whole
city. It's terrible. It must be hard.
It was hard when I was living there and
now it's got to be way worse than I ever
want to move to another city
though. Yeah. But then I go,
not la like I just remember it's
not la and then I go back here.
But don't you ever want to live
in a city city again though or no?
Not with the kid. I think
it's to get rid of him. Now,
here's what's hard about SF.
Is that just getting groceries?
Like you don't have a car there cause
it's so hard to have a car because there's
no parking. You still want to
live on the ocean though, right?
Ocean beach front 100%. You
love Moraine. I live in Marin,
Marin county across the Golden Gate
Bridge there and would live in here in La
County. If you live anywhere. Beach beach
side, anywhere mountain Maribou. Yeah.
Besides, uh, Santa
Monica. Monica Santa. No.
Redondo. Venus Manhattans for no,
like Manhattan Man's to Broey.
Sometimes for me it boils down her most
is actually the mode that's to broey.
Yeah. For Life. Yeah. Like maybe
you're the fucking thing bro. Yeah,
but now I like more seclusion. I don't
like as many people at Palo Sverre days
so far though.
I know our Oxnard's too far north.
I know the most desirable places are
the ones here and they're so expensive.
I know. Can I tell you why I want
us to retire though? Maui, Maui,
we're all like the, the nut bet. Like
the Wayne Dyers, the Doreen Virtue's,
all these nut bags that I like.
Like we're all the,
the meditation retreats are like
with Ron doss again to Maui.
I've never been there either, but I feel
like you and I would really enjoy it.
Wrote down. I think you and I would
really dig Hawaii. It's like a retirement,
eh, Eh, Eh,
I don't really mind telling Nike. Yeah.
That was crazy fun. Fuck yeah it was,
but I wouldn't live there cause there
was only like 3000 people on that,
too small. Not too small, but I
always got it going on and that's,
that's pretty accessible.
We can eat snack,
a Damien nuts every day
cause they're there. That's,
that's where they come from. Row
Out of the ground. They're there.
You just walk around in their
snack. A Damien net. It's
everywhere. People just go.
Do you want a glass of pineapple?
Pineapple.
That's right guy. You're so smart.
You're so smart. Can we talk about our,
Our dad's day and my smurf day yesterday.
Yesterday you Sir Paul Mccartney.
Yup.
My niece Grayson. Yup. Some other kid,
Isabella Rossellini all had birthdays.
Yeah, yeah, sir. Paul Mccartney.
That's what he likes me to call him.
And Sir Paul and I spent the
morning stuck on a plane.
I woke up, I slept for
three hours, was fun and uh,
but you got me this gorgeous ring. Thank
you very much. It's a really outstanding,
I'm going to wear it on my specialty
thing. He did a wonderful job.
You don't know when you buy jewelry for
someone. You're like, did I do well?
I love it. No, until they actually, you
can tell by the reaction. You were like,
what? You know why? Because I'm so
eastern block that I immediately think,
how much did you pay for this?
I don't deserve this.
I don't want to wear something expensive.
I get that.
Or a card or Ellis is college. Yeah.
I'm glad we spent it wisely. Yeah.
Well I get on him to go to Yale for
four years or do you want to eat a ring?
That's what I decided on. I know. I
just get weird about jewel jewelry.
It's a nice ring jewelry. That's how
you say it. Jewelry, not jewelry.
Jewelry is free and wanted a contest
as you get this shooting hoops.
Yeah.
Well then so you got me the super nice
ring and you got me some PJ's like
talking about Pj's and you put your pj's
on at night. I'm not really a PJ guy.
No. I like boxers, but
it's one of those things.
Do you ever have things where you go,
you imagine you want to be that thing?
You know what I mean? Like, yeah.
I'm the same way with robes.
Basically I see someone in a robe.
I'm like,
I want that row and then I get a robe.
I use it twice. I know I lose it.
I forget where it is in the house.
Pj's I see someone in a and like an a
catalog wearing their and I'm like, ah,
it looks so comfortable.
I like sleeping in boxers.
That's how I feel about high heels.
Like I'll buy a pair. I wear them.
Once you write the exception for the
PJ's thing is sometimes they make like
sleep shorts or the
real loose baggy shorts.
I like those to sleeping,
but I don't like an actual Pajama
Ensemble. You know, I don't wear it.
It's a little corny for guys.
Some guys are into it. You know,
those guys are non your reward for those.
Yeah,
they're definitely challenging
the intersectional narrative,
if you know what I mean. I
read that too. It's to cry.
It's just like the gays that somebody,
this orange is the new black actress
is non binary and somebody for real
mountain bike and she really is out
and she's, she's really, how are you?
What's your name? What's Your Pronoun?
You're gonna die. You're gonna die.
Can I read you what she wrote today?
Her name is a Asia Kate Dillon.
She's,
she's one of the white
girl white supremacists
character. So your name again?
Asia.
Kate Dillon.
And she plays one of the,
like I said,
one of the white supremacist girls on
orange is the new black. So she wrote,
I think people receive my message of
being nonbinary and feeling she's really
pretty and she's a great actress.
Uh,
receive my message of being nonbinary
and feeling gender identity as a spectrum
better because I'm white,
was assigned female at birth and
on a super popular television show,
Asia answers. Honestly, my friends
who were assigned male at birth,
people of color,
particularly those who identify as
Fem have an incredibly hard time.
They're ostracized, ostracized, and
there are very few safe spaces for them.
I'm grateful for my visibility and the
conversations that are happening now.
And I just, I like the
comment. So someone wrote,
thank you Asia for complicating the
narrative and keeping it intersectional.
I don't even know what that means
either as why I love it. Oh wait. Okay.
So she's on this new show.
She's the new non nonbinary Jillian
on billions. Yeah, she's on shift.
You're calling her a she and we don't
know if that's her preferred Pronoun,
but Oh,
you said her again to shit.
But this person is on both shows.
Yes.
Billions and black. She's just
killing it. They're killing. Sorry.
They're killing it.
There is this other person writes,
there's also living in a country where
the language doesn't gender neutral
pronouns.
So you have to invent them and that
makes it harder for people to understand.
All right, so, uh, what else
you got other things going on?
Maybe happening.
I don't know why it makes me
laugh so hard on this stuff.
I know that God love him. The God
help these people. Remember that kid?
Jesus Christ. Oh, poopy kisses. Memory.
You wanted me to bring back poopy kisses?
Yeah, I made a note of it. Who'd cases?
Yeah. You said to me the other day,
we got to bring back poopy kiss. It's a
nice way to spin. So you're farting. Yeah.
You're, you're farting poop because
it's a pubic has for your face.
Feel like I need to call airy call
arrows. Uh, I don't know. Let me see.
Because he doesn't understand. He
doesn't like texts like a normal person.
He has like a flip phone. Yeah. He's
so weird. Yeah, it's super annoying,
Huh? Cheers. I was joking with me. All
right, hold on. He's not dying here. Oh,
he's here. Let's stop for a second. Let's
go get them. Let's challenge. All right.
Yeah. We had to, we had to put, we
mentioned it earlier, but it's official.
It's now a thing.
It's here.
Sorry.
Guest has arrived. You'll
Joe mother fucker. Yo.
Aristotle Shaffer.
So welcome Mary Ari is that
here's my ex and my son on,
sorry. Sorry. Hold on, hold
on, hold on, hold on. Gimme
a second. Gimme a second. Um,
wait a minute. Nope. Nope.
How about now? Yeah. Oh,
can you hear yourself? That's beautiful.
Thank you. Now we got it work though.
Is Ari a Hebrew for like, can I get a
discount? What does that actually mean?
Yeah.
Actually I hope a bloggers writing this.
I will know blogger ever defend the
Jews taking your piss for 15 years.
Yeah. What is Arie? Short form? It's all
pronounce Ari. Uh, it is a show for Aria.
Arielle Eliahu Aria. It means RDA
means a lion and Hebrew. Oh boy.
A lion. Yeah. Wow. I on my hair
was way more resembling. Yeah,
I think you're meant to have crazy
hair. Oh yeah. It was great. Great Hair.
I see people now with the bushy fuck, you
know, yeah. Ball. And I'm like, God damn.
Yeah. What's your middle name? David.
And in English and in Hebrew it. So Ari,
who already
are you? David, if you ask
any Jew if their name is not
David, if you would like,
what's your middle name? Just
guest David. By the way, I always,
this always makes me crazy when people
are on as guests on podcasts including
when I've been guest on podcasts and it's
like hey I have something and then we
don't address it forever.
Yeah,
so I think at least once
right out of the gate,
let's mention that on July 9th 18th 18th
Ari Shaffir has a Netflix special set
it called. I'll take those two
pennies and it's coming out.
It's a double special.
Is that actually what that would
be a good name for this special,
I'll take those two petites and the
double special that I would actually work,
I didn't think of it is a double special.
Does it work like the way Chappelle's
does where it's like a collection and like
one place and the pills are like,
I don't know why they do it like that.
They're unrelated.
Completely.
But that is that yours is actually two
separate things will play. Wow Dude,
that's incredible.
I really envisioned it that way.
Does that sound through street?
But that's where you really get to finish
a special yeah. Start number two. Start.
I'm going to take a break. Unreal
man. So I don't understand.
So you'll film I'm a year
apart or simultaneous? No,
I filled them summer tat.
So I had, I did a cap city
and um, I changed clothing.
I finished it. Thank you. Good night.
And then the claps and I was like, Hey,
don't go anywhere.
That's what got like a shitload left.
And then I changed clothes on
stage. You changed the, set it off.
She just said we left cause I
want it to have a similar look.
So I changed it to like
the lighting switch,
just like distressed wood background.
And I changed the back lighting and the,
and the foreground lighting.
I flipped him for the second one
and then I changed my clothes.
Similar but different.
I know,
but like why don't you tell them
the kind of the concept? Yeah.
Half of it's about children and my
feelings of it. So it goes up. Your cute,
it's fun, right? It's
not exactly a mystery.
Why won't you let me touch him?
Is it because of germs or,
or to encourage a stranger?
Strange men naturally good boundaries.
In other words,
some kids his age, uh, uh,
somebody goes like, hey, like that.
And they run up and hug him. Our
kid doesn't do this. Trust people.
Fuck are you looking for yeah.
Yeah, it's great. Um, I as you know,
have contacts at Netflix and I reached
out and was able to obtain a clip from.
Yeah. So here's a little taste better.
The Jews of the Western Wall. No, no,
it's not.
Okay.
I fucking knew it.
I fucking know.
And this is not even an
Orthodox Bar Mitzvah is a woman.
Doing it on a lot in my
upbringing is terrible. Wild.
So talk more about your upbringing,
the way the children not having kid or
your feelings about children is one.
And then what's the other
thing is about adulthood.
So I give it up for kids a little bit.
I understand small parts of them,
but then the other side is like a life
where you really just can't have, if you,
if you have like a wife and kids.
Yeah.
Like can I give you a perfect example
that like it just shows you kind of
different thoughts. Yeah. You, I'm going
to New York. Yeah. And you're like,
why aren't you staying for
like a few days? And it's the,
it's the normal thought for a single
guy that doesn't have a family,
but like any guy with a family
would be like, what are you talking?
Why would I stay there for a few days?
I actually lived most of my life to,
you said it once where it's like, Oh man,
I wish I could do it. I think it was,
I moved to New York, like, I wish I
could do that. I'm like, why don't you,
you're like, I'm married. And
I was like, Oh yeah. Hmm. Yeah.
I mean I wish I could do it in
the sense that it's like I go,
I wish I could fucking go parasailing
tomorrow too. Right, right, right, right.
It's an enjoyable kind of like, oh,
that's cool you get to, but I mean,
I'm not going to do that.
You know?
You know what's funny
when I think about Ellis,
there's only a couple of real things I
I don't like about having a kid like,
and this is so stupid,
but I don't like not sleeping as much
as we used to or sleeping in motherhood.
That is the only thing that
really bothers me. Number one,
I covered that in a special
tiredness that all you guys,
but it's then you weigh it against this
thing called ambivalence where you're
able to simultaneously have
contradictory feelings.
I learned about this and not
everything is black and white.
I didn't know those things are not and
most people are not black and white.
We tried to make everybody black and
white like that guy sucks. She's great.
Killed somebody like I know what the
charity is still works. Of course,
most people are complicated.
It's all good to go to Fiji and that
we're going to have to put off. Right,
and that's something we could literally
do. Why don't you borrow? Granted.
I'm not telling how to parent your kid.
You look,
why don't you leave a bunch of
food in a bowl and then just like
cover up the sockets
with his little covers,
teach them resilience, self
sufficiency. Now your upbringing,
you are orthodox Jews. We know
now. Did your mom wear a wig?
Like is it that Orthodox man? Yeah,
my sister was away all the time.
My mom would generally wear like a hat
except like high holidays and then sure.
Where we're going to had I thought,
I think I wonder if she
would kind of wicked anymore.
Have you seen her naturally at
home? She's fine. And what was she,
a blonde or something? Naturally
she's been dying her hair for so long.
I think she's great naturally. Is that
possible? Not, yeah, I think she's blonde.
Crazy guys.
What do you think I should take
the 10 10 flight or the 11:15 PM
10 oh, what time are you trying
to get in? Well, that's the thing.
They get in about an hour apart,
either our six 45 or seven 45 six 45
to traffic where you're going through.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
Did it take me an hour and a half to
get to my hotel when I did got them? Oh,
it's nothing. I don't know whether
it's no good subway system.
I know why it's a cabs and the union
field won't allow the subway to go all the
way there anyway. So do you think
it's rooted in your, did you do,
did you hate your childhood? Is that
when you man, I loved it. I loved it.
Seriously. Child is the best. What
are you talking about? Oh yeah.
I didn't have a crazy mom was there not
trying to commit suicide in front of me
because you think that somebody
with my background with,
cause I used to be like that too, where
I was afraid of, I didn't want a family.
I didn't really think I would end
up marrying. But now that I have,
and I love it because I
liked the stability and the
security with most people
though. Right. What's going to have kids?
They're like, oh that is what I like.
So how, what, what like where, what
was the defining moment for you?
Where you're like,
I know for me I think it's more reason
where I was like for awhile I was like,
of course I'll have kids
we're supposed to do.
And then I lost my religion
and then it was like,
and I moved out here 25 and ask you
this when you told me one time about no,
no,
about stopping the religious thing.
How much you research that borrow
Fatone I clip real quick. Sorry.
Was it a light bulb moment?
What was that like abandoning religion?
Was it like a one like you're
like fuck that dates back to a,
to a thing that it took me like a
year to like ponder in my head until I
realized, oh, but you really
did ponder for a while then.
And what was the epiphany?
Was it that God doesn't exist or that
this particular system of religion is not?
I don't have a belief in it. I first,
I was like gnostic where I was like,
I don't know. It was
cute. I was sleeping in a,
in a dorm and he is
Shiva in Israel. And, um,
we had a light bulb over the
beds for reading and, um,
you could like twist it up and I remember
this, I do see this is the story. Yeah,
you can put a cup on top of it. So
John at the light. So I was like, cool,
I can sleep.
But then the cop kept like sliding off
cause it's like circular frame to it and
it just keeps sliding off. And I was
like, maybe I'll just turn the light off.
But my, my door was like, my window
was like right by the entrance to the,
to the dorm. So I'm like, people are going
to see if I turn my light off and it's,
everyone's like religious Jewish.
You can't do it on Friday night.
You weren't allowed to have a
light. Sorry, I skipped. Yeah,
you can't use electricity sabbath.
Yeah.
You can leave it on I'll all the whole
time or you can turn it off the whole
time. Oh, go on and off. So drowning
it out as, okay. It's still on.
You're not changing the spark.
Uh, this is such weird shit,
but like a distinction to make.
Yeah.
It's funny too how many of those things
are like tied to a practice and they
become symbolic but,
but,
but their actual origin is not like,
no,
but I'm saying like with food eating,
let's say, right, like people stay away,
I don't know from certain foods,
but the origin of that was
like a practical thing, you
know? Right. They would say,
yeah, like some, like some
foods wouldn't, you know,
hold well for certain people get sick.
So they go,
we don't eat that and then years later
they don't get sick. That sort of thing.
Yeah. Yeah. But why did they
become symbolic? I'm just eating
rob.
I was always just,
so the reason we don't need stuff is not
because of like tape worm or anything,
just because God said, oh well
nevermind. Practical reasons that,
but that's probably,
if God was invented,
that's probably one of the things
that were in his epiphany though.
I the thing wouldn't stay
on, I kept thinking like,
I'll just turn my light off.
I just turn it off,
which you're not allowed to do.
But that was looking to get caught.
And then I thought about
it later where it's like,
who am I worried about
getting caught by man or God?
And if I really believe in God,
who didn't want me to do that,
then I wouldn't even be a question.
You don't do that. Yeah. So I was like,
why am I questioning it?
And it finally came to light.
I don't think I believe in God.
I don't think it's in me.
And then once I figured that out,
I was like, I think I should stop.
And I went to Taco Bell. You turn that
light off, Huh? Where were you at?
A university in New York and like a
Spanish Harlem one 85th and Amsterdam.
You went to Taco Bell?
I want to talk about I barfed.
Yeah.
What did you order? What was the
onpro 20 Tacos for fucking $1 off,
whatever it is. I don't know if it
was because of shitty food or dealt.
I'm not really sure. We've been such big
fans of Neil Hamburger. Look that up.
I'll pull it up right now. Neil
hamburgers because he started to change.
No, the comment, you know him
right? Uh, hold on. It's so funny.
His Twitter feed is great.
Oh really?
He does this semi-regularly where
I want to talk about this brown.
I had no let's not,
let's not lose track of his uh,
his story here either.
But yeah
you just mentioned this. Did you get so
much stuff going on and got to like, yeah.
So he finds people's tweets about getting
sick from Taco Bell and research and
there's a lot of them. Oh my God. So
like go ahead and read it out loud.
I want to talk, I want to talk
about the last time I had it,
I almost thought the Taco Bell I work
at got mice and bugs all over this,
their place, this sick fuck a Nigga got
food poisoning from tuck about cause
I don't know if that meant
because or cousin I was for sure.
I did a presentation today on back on
the bacteria that cause food poisoning.
I think I got food poisoning from
talking about ironic as fuck.
Talk about getting to cover,
talking about,
talking about for the food poisoning.
The day after graduation,
my boyfriend and I never had
a wheel is Burt taco bell.
This rope food endless,
and he does this every few months.
Wow.
One day day.
It wasn't like isolated over three years.
I found a roach in my food. Never
went back there. Also wrote Shit.
I'm mad at Taco Bell. I'm a cart.
Had a whole fat ass ratchet,
chill in the lobby.
So the Taco bell diarrhea thing is true
about here's what golf go a little Taco
bell three years ago.
Went to Los Lunas domestic.
We'll talk about founder here in our food.
Went back today,
founder here on our food.
That's for me twice. Yeah.
My friend got to talk about it and went
to the hospital when again the next day
and got food boy. He's like, I can't
believe it. I can't believe it. Yeah.
Taco bell never fails to
give me food poisoning.
Your nasty ass food establishment
gave me food poisoning. Taco Bell.
Never again food. The words food
poisoning I'm talking about.
I think you just has to search.
Let's talk about that book comes
up. No. Yeah. Food poisoning.
Three different times.
I done when I,
so I wanted to talk about today in Mount
Vernon and I'd done God pours like or
some shit like God bro, really
be shitting. I am crazy.
Sean Fan Account.
Oh Fan. I that was her. I almost
my heart but isn't in the uh,
the amount of them astounding like
this many people. This is countless.
Well, you know, the meat
is supposedly supposedly,
supposedly worse than prison.
This blessed one here
and Taco bell are good. That shit
has a Nigga suit. Well accessed.
I don't care for your choice of words,
but uh, central med I can come up like,
oh damn, that's great. Yeah, I
love what are good cops like that?
Just senators on top. Like you ever see
Colin Quinn's like a tongue in cheek?
Like, oh, we're conservative tweets.
Yeah. That's so funny. Oh, his Twitter
account. It never lets it and I'm joking.
Never know that would be
like, yeah. And it's partly,
you have to like really,
except that, that,
that there's gonna be people out there
that believe that you're serious.
And I think that's a real
struggle for like a lot of comics.
But I think that he is so
that he fully goes for it. Also,
if you don't fool a few people,
it's just not quite as fun.
Exactly.
Any Kaufman how to get people to like
get the fuck off stage or it'd be like,
I like his spirit,
his stuff.
Like there's just nothing like hearing
laughter out there healing the healing
power of laughter like Collin tweets,
that kind of shit.
Yeah.
That's a smart move.
Done that with Rogan instead of
covering them up. I don't know.
I think that that might be true. I
don't think it's made for that. Exactly.
Your mom's stomach for those.
Hey Dude, what are you doing?
I'm sorry your mom has made for
holding up my mark. Stern. Thanks.
Glad you're here because you and I,
we share a common bond that
we both love to shit and yeah,
every time I mentioned it people
like, Oh Christina. I'm like, Oh yeah.
I guess we do have our
kindred poos barely on. Yeah,
we got this big day toilets.
The US who goes straight to the shower.
You saved money on toilet paper
first of all, beside the point,
but is it that flip thing?
Yeah. Uh, second of all,
it's the clinic you can get.
It's the cleanest. No drawing. No John.
Now what mud you to shit to shower.
I want to talk about
your experience with it.
I believe the first time was kind of like
my epiphany with Judaism where it was
just like, it just sort of happens. You
know? I was had no toilet paper. Oh,
I looked under the sink.
Oh I think I did. Yeah.
I think it was in my old place on sunset
and I looked into this thing and I was
like, no. I'm like fuck,
what am I going to do? Huh?
And then it hit me straight to shower
straight down. That's interesting.
Cause it necessity is the mother
of invention. It is now with me.
It was that I have what is
known as the never ending wipe.
I get leaky button where I wiped by wiped
by wipe and the paper's always brown
and I found that the only way to stop
the breach is if I shower my butthole.
Yeah. Then the brown stops
coming down. You get like greasy,
Greasy League rec league. It's just
solid brown. No, no. It's like a mush.
Just like a, like a s schmear.
Oh yeah. Like I don't know.
I don't know what that is. Like a
sun dried tomato cream cheese. Yeah.
Small. But anyway, we got this new toilet,
this robot toilet that, those
are great. It's a wash led.
It's a big day in your toilet and
you don't have to go into the shower
physically. Right. Cause some of
that's annoying. Like I don't want to
my pants off. Take a towel to dry
off this thing though. This thing,
what's amazing is you have different
water pressure options. Oh,
oscillating pulsating options. What do
you mean water temperature options? Yeah.
Cold, warm, hot. Yup. It's pretty
amazing. So basically you can,
you're done. Yeah. You can have
a nice stream to kind of start.
Kind of get your ass holiday it.
Yeah.
And then you can fucking gas it
up and have a fire hose and wow.
And really get,
get it gone away that you couldn't be,
you can let that thing run for a minute.
Put toilet paper back there.
Nothing going clean as a west side.
And there's a drier cat. Barilla.
Explain this to me once about wet,
wet, wipe it as opposed to dry wine.
You know what though? I find, what have
he said? I don't think that's enough.
We'll just in general using water. Water's
great. Yeah. He said he's, I was like, no,
I just use it was back
then. And he goes, oh no,
you can actually do the
toilet paper. Yeah. And he was
like, look, and he took some,
a little bit of Coca Cola. Yeah. Put
It on my table. And then he goes, okay,
let that sit for a minute now wipe it
up with a dry towel and that feel the
table. I'm like, yeah, a little sticky
goes. Yeah, a little sticky. Yeah.
Get some water. I didn't know
that he was such an expert that
questions for rem. So fascinating. So
I'll tell you about Southeast Asia toilet.
Oh, I can't. Okay, wait, wait. Hold on.
I'll save it. Save it. Okay. Wait, wait.
I've been dying to talk to
you about this. Okay. Yeah.
So now when you do shit
to shower in your world,
do you do a cursory wipe and exploratory
wipe or you literally dump your shit
straight to shower without
even a cursory wipe?
Okay. I'm going to ask you, you have
your opinion later. What do you do?
Occasionally I'll go.
Nothing but cause doesn't really.
I'll do it constantly wipe because
it's like, what if you trip on the way?
It depends if I have a bathmat.
There you have it.
I don't want to ruin a bathmat full dump.
Fulled up.
Just stand up and go in the shower.
Well I can reach over from the tour that
I turned the hot water on other places
a little harder. Um, but yeah,
just go full and then we get to
watch all the shit rundown. The sick.
I can psycho. Remember in psycho,
which is bleeding out and the drain,
the drain blood, you get that
you guys have run down your leg,
which is usually horrible,
but it's not going to stick.
Right? It's your shower. What
do you do? Okay. Now because
he's a little bolt,
it's on all the time thing for me.
And I do live with someone
so I try to be considered,
I wouldn't put Dukie he's
not in the bathroom. Yeah.
But he's going to shower there after
me and I don't want shit in our shower
necessarily. Right. So I do an
exploratory consideration. Why have now?
Sometimes I have just known. I'm like,
that wasn't a massive brown. There's not,
there's nothing on my asshole
that was a clean break. It's fine.
All right.
We kind of stay here for this,
uh, this noise. This is like the tickets,
tickets as a journalist writing
stories about, I was like seven feet,
but um,
yeah,
I'll only do it if I'm confident that
there's no brown on my butt hole.
I will just go straight to shower if I'm
confident and, and sometimes I am. Okay.
You have a bleed out of my vagina. Yeah.
Oh, right, right. It's different. Yeah.
That's normal. Yeah. Do you, are you
still bleeding out of your asshole?
Not Through my whole
chip in Southeast Asia.
And when I got back the second day was
full blood ago. No strippers. Really.
He's talking about this.
What do you think? Wow.
Do you think that is an
internal hemorrhoid? I've
asked the doctor. He was like,
you're good at that. Blood's too
dark. Do you see any of this in Asia
so far? Yes. Flute. I
don't know what she was.
Was putting your list the
way you play flute? I know
who the other people, oh, oh,
holy shit.
Oh,
she's putting other two
seem shocked or animate.
Wow. Flute with her VGM guys. You do that.
Could you push out air that way? No,
I've never been able to Queef on command.
Now he's loving it. She's like, what the,
that's a real talent though.
She's also playing a tune.
She's not just blowing out anyways. Also
hitting the keep. That's right. Yeah.
It's a real skill.
Anything like that you see in your job.
Last time I went to Thailand
like two years ago, what's a, uh,
a pop harm the street in
Thailand at a women? These women,
is that Bangkok, Bangkok. They
gave you a rolled up piece of, uh,
well first they give a balloon, like hold
it above your head and you're like, why?
Boy? And then they shoot darts out of
the vaginas and pop your balloon. Wow.
Then you applaud for that. I assume it's
not sexual at all. It's just talents.
Then you roll up a piece of paper into
a funnel, hold that over your head like,
what are you doing? And then they start
peeling bananas and you're like, no.
And then they ship it out and get
it into the Little Cup you've made.
What's the trick? What's the, there's,
there's gotta be a circus trick.
Their practice,
they get to Carnegie Hall.
That can't be legit. No Way, man. That
I've seen, they put it in there, pops out.
Wow. I don't have a
vagina. I don't know. Wow.
Got to be able to suck air in
before you put the object in.
Because I've seen girls
that can queef on command.
I've had friends that can do it and you
lay on your back and you suck in the air.
I had a roommate that did
that with his asshole. No, no,
no, just the air thing. But like
right on, like he would just get on,
he could do it on all fours or lay
on his back and just all day he'd go.
Really? Yeah. Wow. What a
superhero. It was really cool.
Yeah. I wonder if they have like
a wrestling style school for that,
for shooting stuff out of your vagina
where it's like you're not ready yet,
but I want to get my accreditation. Let's
talk about the toilets in Asia. Okay,
so they have these, if they're not squat
toilets, I hate those. They're pretty bad.
I hear that it's better for you.
I love how much removed ourselves
from people actually hiring us.
No apology necessary to look
somebody.
It's an Asian person saying it so
it's not an impression. Yeah, there's
just giving out directions. Who knows?
So they have the squatters,
they had the squad,
but a lot of times will they have
toilets in hostels and stuff.
They have toilets, but they have
these bum guns, which is just like,
you know how I want to sync, you'll
get like the thing you get to pull out.
And as a host, but without the,
uh, the, um, what's it called?
The spray.
So it's just a street and you put that
into your butt or towards your butt and
you just spray it out.
And then like you said,
you've got that one wipe and it's
almost clean. Did you like that?
Did you prefer that to your LLC? Yeah,
you can't throw out. I got used to it.
No Shit shouts the best. But you can't
throw out your toilet paper in the toilet.
Right? Cause they all still up.
Throw in the trashcan. Fal is shit.
It smells horrible.
So one of my good friends is married to
a woman from Mexico and when her family
came, they would throw stuff out
in the Trashcan, toilet paper like,
but like I love it. Used
toilet paper, toilet paper,
and you guys don't have a
bum gone. So like, aw yeah.
So there's this big wads of shit.
Not like they're getting one last white,
they're doing the whole thing in there.
And he was like,
you gotta stop doing this.
And they just so habitual,
we're talking like their 40 years
of doing this. So they put some,
he had a type signs you put flushing.
Yeah, that's, that's the, uh,
the opposite of that in those
hostile where it's like, Hey,
I know you used to where you are. You
can't flush toilet over here. Uh Oh, hey,
I had a question. Oh Hey,
we had an email today.
How do blind people know
when to stop wiping?
What are your thoughts on that test?
And their sense of taste
is higher than most people
thought it was a thing where
they eventually do a bare
hand thing and then they
just go, oh, there's nothing
there. But they'd have to like,
they couldn't go like half of that. I
want to how close I am. Right, right.
Like you look at toilet paper when
you're out, when you don't have a shower,
you look at it, you're like,
okay, I'm about halfway there.
You look at it three quarters of
the way there. Yeah, that's true.
You don't just keep going until it like,
this feels dry. Oh, I've been way done.
Right, right, right. Maybe
you smell the toilet paper.
Why do you have to smell your bare
hand? Oh, that's a great tweak.
What you just did right? He just stepped
it up a great, wait, what are you saying?
Because I'm an observational
person. Why? Why are you,
why do they have to smell their bare hand?
Like you said,
why not smell the toilet paper?
Oh, I see what that's like
because one of them told me this what they
do really well. So I got this for you.
Park with a Ryan O'Neal and uh,
I mean 10 middleware,
Griffith Park, just walking
around. Okay. And uh,
10 minutes in I was like, I didn't shut
this morning and I have to shit. Ooh.
He's like, really? I'm like, no, I'll
hold it, hold it three more minutes.
Like I'm not holding it, man. I got to go.
He was like, how are you going to wipe?
And I'm like, well, he had a full bottle
of water. I'm like, put that. He was like,
what do you, what? What do
you mean no, don't do this?
And I was like, yeah, I have.
Did it have the sports top?
Just kind of like one of these
arrowhead bottle and then, uh,
I shit on a hill so it really squat shot,
which I'm used to now I've got experience.
You get away from people got out and went
down the hill a little bit, cut to it.
Got to like a big Bush behind me.
So people that were on the road
on the path that I could see.
If you were way down and you looked up,
you could for sure see a man squatters.
They thought it was homeless.
I didn't have my shirt on
the squatting technique because I imagine
what's problematic is that you might
shit on your jeans. Absolutely.
You learned to lean backwards.
There's also a pull your
jeans forward. Let me, uh,
let the legs. Yeah, hold
on. Um, I I want to watch,
I don't need to see that.
You pretty much get the idea from,
you want to go around the corner there.
He's got his pants down right now.
He's got some mushroom boxer
shorts and he's standing and show,
sorry. Pulled his pants
down to his underwear. Dan,
please put them back on for the lab.
We have dogs in here.
He's showing,
please don't pull your pants down.
Squatting right into the pan. He's
squatting, but you're squatting straight.
So everything's at a perfect angle.
Yes. Okay, so you're hanging,
your pants are now above.
Okay, so you're really,
the key is that you really
squat back a little bit.
You squat full shots, right, Tom? Oh God.
The touching the toilet is a real
issue. I have big long balls. Yeah.
So that's an issue. But I was on a hill
and Griffith Park. No big deal right now.
When you were doing that at Griffith Park,
what about the weeds and the brush
touching your dick and your balls and your
butthole and all that?
Some dried leaves definitely touched it.
Didn't care for it.
So you're saying it's all about the lean,
like what you kind of did the way you
were squatting is how I've seen like
Chinese guys smoking in Chinatown.
Yeah, they're used to it.
They always sit like that. Yeah. The slot,
the Stud fullback squats up with Dan.
Your balls are so big,
so big. So then I poured
water on my, my hands
immediately as it's wet, took it to the
butt and kind of wiped. Oh you take,
you did it with your hands and then it
got more water. Wipe more water wife? No,
didn't dig in with nails,
didn't want to stick my nails and then
I was forced by Ryan to wipe my hands in
dirt afterwards. Yeah. And then you
wash your hands later. I'm hoping. Yeah.
How much?
Like do you get a lot of ball attention
when you're with like are they like,
oh he's a great ball of like the big
thing with a couple of times. Yeah.
I've had a couple girls go like,
man I love these balls really?
But like twice now. Are you really into
your own balls then? Like is that a big,
like if you were making your list where
you're like definitely like play with my
balls. I think. Comedically they're good
weapons. Yeah. How saggy they are. Yeah.
I mean if there were a nice tight
ones it wouldn't be as funny as it is.
It really a turn. I'm saying like if, if
you were like, if a woman was like, what,
what do you like what we're about
to have sex? Where you'd be like,
definitely play with my balls.
Okay.
So it's not like your thing
I'm saying I don't mind it.
It's kind of Nice actually,
but it's not like I need that.
It's not like you need it.
You, I mean, I like it,
but I mean it's not like I wouldn't be
like, if you don't tell on my balls,
we had a problem. How big
were Ari's balls? They just,
why not looking at all was like six balls.
The left one has a lot lower.
Like a, it looked like a half
mad pizza dough kind of thing.
There was just like,
it didn't look too hairy.
Got a glimpse.
Kind of like a teenager's beard.
Just an occasional in who there
you do a lot of trimming or no,
nothing really zip. I got
to do a lot of that. Really?
No, no. What are you half
Peruvian, Peruvian and I, you know,
whatever. But um, it's a lot.
I don't know. It's a lot of
hair. I don't, I'm not like,
oh, actually I have one of my friends
who like him fall down. They're not bald.
I like a good cleanup.
I think that it's important to
at least be a little hygienic.
I don't like so much hair that
it's annoying. It too much. Yeah.
It can get away from you stop storing
at some point though. Yeah, it does,
but sometimes I look down
there, I'm like, oof. Yeah.
I mean I just need like a
haircut. You don't want to
Tuft. Yeah, no, that's gross.
And then it's two velcro
way when it's too long.
Sometimes it looks like the hedge, just
like peeking out of the woods. You know?
Like my Dick just heard something like,
what's going on?
Like groundhog's Day,
a few weeks of winter back in polyps.
Is that what you have polyps? Is that
in your butt hole? You said you have
and can you do something to
stop them from Bono? He said,
I could have surgeries is not worth
it. He's like, it might not work.
And it's just like invasive and you've
never, have you ever seen Jew clam,
excuse me? Or He's going
to show or not right now.
I can't do it. It doesn't sound really,
it's so bad. I saw it in person.
I was like, dude, I was in a
capsule. I wasn't kept city.
Yeah. Re we put that video
out to promote my special.
I saw it and I remember that I pulled,
uh,
I was so traumatized that I
pulled Brian aside was like,
he need to go to the hospital.
I'd never seen anything like that.
I know it's crazy
and that isn't a problem.
Like that shouldn't be surge or whatever.
Is it just that you bleed a lot? It's
like, I mean he really got to see it.
It's like we already have to
blur one puffed up facade.
Yeah. It's so crazy. Like
his basically his,
you ever seen like a chimps ass?
How it's like bubbles.
It's like all big and yes.
Yes. That happens. Vagina.
That happened to him on camera and I
saw him turning and when I saw it I was
like, I literally, I had
never seen anything like this.
I saw this swollen sticking out
of him like peach bread asshole.
And it, it looked like it looked like
it wasn't like your real asshole.
I been trying to push out a shit
for like the last like three,
four straight minutes and I
thought that's what it was.
That shit was halfway out of my book.
So I was trying to show you,
you saw it like, cause you knew
what that was, what it looked like.
I thought there was a piece of shit
coming out of my butt and I was trying to
show you that be the most disgusting
me when you saw it on yourself,
weren't you a little like, oh my God.
Like okay. Yeah. Like it's a little scary,
right? It's a little scary
to see. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But it was like I can search stuff has
been there for awhile, but that's that,
that didn't feel good to wipe it spine.
It's pretty tough.
And then it just kind of goes
back in. It goes back hand. Yeah.
All right.
I mean we've already said wow, is it
when just got to the one not on Youtube,
I think like live leak or something.
Okay. Uncensored on censored Juke. Clam.
But still, it's still like
that, Ari? Yeah. I can show
you right now. No, no, no.
That's okay. Bubby. Yeah.
That's a terrible thing to live.
Bleached out. Punch drunk.
Ah, I saw that on the, uh,
I saw that Sam triple e's. How'd that
go? Did it hurt? No, a little warm.
A little little heat on it. But, uh,
you get to see it before and after shot,
like,
so you could see I've seen it before
or after. It just seemed like the,
the parts that he didn't bleed,
we're just darker.
Didn't look like it was lighter. That's
so funny that people are doing that.
Is that real? I mean, if you're a
porn star, I get it. But otherwise,
in civilian life, why would you
need to have your ass hole? I mean,
once we got into an accident and you
badly burned inside your asshole,
it's aesthetics, guys down. I'm just like,
I'm trying to play it and yeah,
but it just says, you know,
so I go, hit play. I'm hitting play
right now. It's all on video cuts.
It's horrific news today. Must be
over there. Just won't play. Uh,
I wonder if this other one will
play. Oh, here's a reddit link to it.
Maybe this will play.
This is fun.
It's our pizza dish. I'm
thinking of getting one of
those big day. Thanks dude. Uh,
Amazon, you don't have to, she don't
have to like get in the shower.
Did I haven't shit to shower.
I only do it in hotels now.
Cause there was the well yeah they
don't now I feel like a diminished,
degraded human when I have to shit on
a toilet that doesn't have a bad day.
I feel like it's, I feel like trash to
use to it. It's going to change your life.
It's called the toto washlet three 50.
He washlet wash.
Let washlet I dunno, do why
he's saying it like that. Is it,
is it wash let or Washlet washlet Oh,
I thought it was French.
Maybe like two t's and an e and Lit.
Fucking know. But uh, it'll really
change your whole shit game. Yeah,
I might do that. See if you have blood
and stuff down there, you should work.
So now when you do that,
then does a stop with a continuous wiping?
Yeah, it's good. Cleans it up. Wow. The
water is what I need to stop the leaky,
but wow. I don't know why my butt leaks.
Have you ever before you got that,
did you ever wipe say, okay, I think I'm
good. Then go out and go, oh, I think I'm,
I think I've got to go back to wipe.
That's how I've discovered my leaky,
but probably, yeah. And then
like hours later I'll be like,
oh my God, why is there Brown there?
These, these summer days by the way,
summer. Oh Harry. You know like
sometimes I'll be like, ah,
and I'll just go sit down with paper
to see if there's something there.
And you just see so much brands. It's
just like sweat and your, your food.
If you walk around New York City, it's
the same way. Wait, are you going back to
go back on Saturday? Was
confessed. Oh you are? Okay.
Yeah. So I'll be gone. Yeah,
I'm going to be there like a
couple of weeks just hanging out.
If you want to come back. You really
good. I'm just gonna stay. Definitely. No.
Hey, can we see what's up
with Dany Yak? Dany Yak?
Yeah. She's a lady. She's got a
following on, uh, on Youtube. Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah. I mean, you know, I just
been thinking about her. Yeah. Well,
she does this thing where like,
she starts basically all of her
are a lot of her videos like this.
You Go, yes. Hey, what? Hitler. Yeah.
She, how old is that flocks
to Hitler? How old does that
work? Oh, really? Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
She's just addressing all this stuff to
Hitler is on a live Hitler or is it a
back that Hitler I think thinks he's
alive. Distinguished. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
That historical Hitler Hitler of today.
Yeah.
And did she give me like blog type advice
or is she like a admonishing you for
some of this stuff you thought or she
just like, how are you doing? She's like,
I needed some help. Oh, really?
Yeah. It's a cry for him. Wow. Yeah.
Yay.
How are you then
Daniel Lewis?
His basically harassing my
day and he's harassing me.
He's a threatening actually.
Yeah.
Is it the Germans? Yes. Yes. Can rape her.
Right. Why? Why, why, why did he call me
a Danny? I can her rape her or something
like, you know, um,
sacrifice really demon.
He could a look Amin called Pq.
Uh,
he's been suspended my account like a
thousand of times because he's overly
jealous.
She's real a thousand of times.
He basically is least with me.
He doesn't know any thing about me.
Right.
He's in no rush to get to a point.
Hey,
let's got all the time in the world
is watching youtube. He loves you too.
No, but you know, uh, he's
in Patagonia. I just want to tell
watches. Youtube all day. All right.
Can we see the, the, the update? Yeah.
The Wowza a 37,000 views. It's not that
this, yeah, we've been pushy. Has
she said anything to you guys?
Um, well, no, not directly. No.
Would she be upset you had to do on your
podcast? I don't think she'd be a real,
probably at the, she say anything
at they Semitic or, or anything.
I think she, I don't remember.
I don't remember, honestly,
his or her that had an
anti thousands of times.
I just want to let you know the people
in Canaan Tonio the one call me my day
maniacs.
Um,
they are chained up on the
cam and which I changed them.
But um,
no,
it,
the title is there on a
Scampi shrimp Scampi them
and I really need your help.
I'm saving them.
Yeah.
That she hasn't already done.
She's a hero.
This is the one I'm talking about.
Any acts that a shrimp Scampi and getting
turned into like look Guango where's
she from this day?
Aye.
Oh Shit.
Good.
Okay.
The shrimp Scampi.
Hey,
I just want to let you
know there are Italy,
the two my DDX or really to a few of my
dany x better on a shrimp Scampi vote
like they are like getting
turned into Lasagna. So
major help getting everything your
rescue boat over there and uh,
they, uh, they really need
your help getting rescued.
So could you elite please,
please send a rescue boat.
That way they could be saved
to her point. Really
appreciate it, Dave. Okay.
She says Hitler, she sang
Hitler Baby. Oh, for Christmas.
And she sings happy birthday.
Hitler and the submarines.
Right.
I mean it's not out of the realm of like,
no,
no.
I don't know lips.
Yeah, that'd be birthday.
Yeah. Nigger Lips.
I don't know if she's saying saying stuff.
Shrimp Scampi.
Boat problems.
Eylea
way.
Okay.
Actually I get rid of the demons
is to actually say happy Easter.
Bye. Okay. Oh Man. That would've,
that would've made all those diva
movies way lamer. Yeah. Yeah.
The thing I was looking for.
Do you remember her? Um,
one of her oh gee ones was about,
um,
shitting in and around.
Yeah.
I can't find it around and
that's hard to find. Yeah.
We could be looking all day for that. I
know, but she had a great one about, um,
what she was going to do
to, uh, this guy when she,
when she was going to shit in
his mouth and not around it,
but she likes specified where
she was getting. Really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Hit Look,
you're only get a hard,
if you short on his chest was that,
you should talk about that. Like he had
a small Dick and that he had a, yeah,
that's what I always heard when I
was growing or latent. Homosexual.
And how was growing up around
people who didn't like Hitler?
Why you wear the most problem?
I think, uh, they were just, uh,
not fans of the EU. Yeah. I think that's
what he was trying to unite. Yeah. Yeah.
Sorry. We should do, would you rather
with Arie, what'd you rather? Yeah,
like the historical one, the big one.
Oh, okay. Well there's a couple I got.
I just think it'd be fun to
play with them. Yeah, sure.
Would you rather only Lasagna
for the rest of your life? Yeah.
Or never have to never be able
to eat anything with meat?
Nope. One day, one day, one meal a day.
How do we live off your life or no
meat for the rest of the top layer
that goes and checking or
toilet paper. The urine. Homeless.
There's times by my butt.
Sex with your sister.
They the face grandmother
walks on you masturbating,
never have another orgasm.
China,
China, China. Would you rather
I want to hear my options again.
It's either Lasagna,
one meal a day for the rest of
your life. Every day. Every day.
You must eat lasagna high. Does that meat
and veggies your choice. Your choice.
Okay. Um, but you can't eat anything else.
You can have like a little
piece of Lasagna and like
a salad is just as Anya for
a meal. One meal a day. Yeah. You
have two pieces, three pieces,
but for the rest of your life you
get other meals. Dinner. Yeah,
that could just be lunch. Okay. Um,
but you don't get to like have
another thing that you have to eat it,
it to fill up on it. Okay.
That's a, that's a B,
the formula or you're a vegetarian but,
but you're saying no fish as a
vegetarian. Yeah, no fish. So no protein.
You basically have to be like
a Vu may have eggs. I see.
I have to have that protein.
I feel, I feel weird when I
don't have protein. Yeah.
I'm going to have to go with the Lasagna
today. Wow. Cause I like Lasagna.
Like I feel like I could do that.
You don't feel like you'll be betraying
Lasagna by eventually hating it? No.
Okay. No. What? What do you say, Tommy
Jeans? I have to do this right now. Okay.
Our area.
What do you choose?
I didn't really think of what I said
to love me. Pedal Saga every day.
I know it's tough because you know when
you make a Lasagna you end up eating it
for three or four days anyway by
day four you're just overestimate.
So what was the other option
besides a Lasagna? Be a vegetarian.
No fish. You can only have, oof.
I know. Well I think I'd have
to do lasagna every single day.
What if you just ate a
tiny square that allowed?
Not Allowed, but here's the
thing. The variety provided
to you in the other meals,
I think would would counter it. Yeah.
I feel weak when I don't eat meat.
I like meat.
Did you go to a dinner party?
Like we got Lasagna to the, yeah.
You would kill someone? Yeah. Wait,
what would you choose?
I think I'd be a vegetarian.
I think I would get real sick of Lasagna
and I'd start to go crazy. That's true,
but what could it,
could you have different Lasagna is like
with the best Sharm El Sauce one day or
does it have to be the standard tomato
Warfield pictured it was the same exact
recipe. Lasagna. Like when you say you
make a thing of Lasagna of keep eating it.
I imagine like a 50 mile long one.
It's always lasagna fresh or heat it up.
That's the only variety your got.
I put shaky cheese on it one day the
next day. No shaky. I try to vary it.
I think I would have
to do that just to be,
be able to have whatever I want for
the second and the third meal. I agree.
I agree. Okay. Ready? Oh sorry. Go ahead.
This is probably one of our most
favorite ways you rathers on the show.
Very popular.
It would you rather be retarded.
Hold on.
I'll stop you there. I would love to.
I, you're gonna give me another positive
or be a millionaire that I don't know,
but like I would love the
lack of responsibility you
must feel would be so worth
it. You really need to throw
in the towel. I mean, you know
who's going to do that chore? Well for
sure not me, right? Because I'm retarded,
so for sure it's not me. However,
you guys can decide who's doing it,
but I'm out of this.
Can I just go pee corner?
Thank you. Have a job like
you have to go. How many jobs?
I remember that commercial
when you were little.
Do you remember that? Like,
yeah, we played it on the show.
What you have to go work at the
grocery story and have to bag groceries
pushcarts stuff like that. When you get
a retarded guy back in your groceries,
does part of you feel like
I'm part of the solution?
I've said this is one of my favorite.
I love doing this to people. I did
this to my mother. We were at a grocery
store and they had a retarded guy
bagging the groceries and he wa at this
grocery store.
They walk you to the car too.
So they walk to the car and they load
it in and so he did, he did all that.
There's no conversation. And then as
we're getting in the car turn on long ago,
someone was different about that guy.
Right?
He's retarded.
He also doesn't know like PC
things to say and she's like, I go,
no. She goes, tell me please. And I go,
he's fine.
But he was like off and he's clearly,
and she's just like, just upset. I do
that also when I see somebody walking,
like, you know, fuck with her, like with
them, with my parents, I'll be like,
this guy's drunk still.
And she'll be like,
but they don't like, they
don't go, they don't get that.
I'm saying that as a jokes. I do it
seriously. And then there'll be like,
that guy's severely disabled. Like
he's, he's fucked up and they're light.
And I'm like, oh, he's drunk, but
you could sell it. I liked it.
Then my friend's like,
oh,
look at this soccer on the 80 year old
man I fucking asshole in to see somebody
super hot. Like what Tom does is when
he sees a pregnant woman, he'll be like,
what's wrong with her stomach?
I have a stupid,
I posted that on Instagram before and
it's almost like that Collin, when thing,
we were talking about some people
going to be pregnant and I'm like,
no dude. I post with
Adam West side. I was,
I had this contract with our fans.
A celebrity dies as soon as possible.
I will shit on him as soon as they died.
As soon as I hear about it,
I will try to come up with a funny
tweet shitting on them. Yeah.
Not Respecting their death.
Yeah. So for Adam West,
because I didn't really have any problems
at all with Adam West. Yeah. I was like,
um,
Adam with Fox,
my grandmother tore apart my fat and
my father's family, I saw that. I saw,
I'll never forgive him. I'm Moshe
Kasher was like, is that real?
You fucking idiot.
Tore my family apart.
Sorry sir.
Would you rather be retarded or let your
grandfather jerk you off on a Ferris
wheel?
But you get,
you get a funnel cake to
choose the Ferris wheel,
a funnel cake. And all he does
is he does, he drops you off on,
no one finds out and you get an
awesome fresh funnel cake. Go ahead.
Does a funnel cake come before or after
the jerk off on the first one after.
So it's like you're done. You're crying.
So it doesn't make you feel better.
This is our thing. Like don't tell
anybody here's a funnel. Yeah.
Feel like the experience of having the
funnel cake with Papa would be a sort
of tainted from the Turk off it is.
It is by you.
Here's the thing.
But if I get the final cake before,
it'd be a nice moment with my,
with my, with my papa or my Saba.
But then afterwards I'd be like nothing
to wash down that bad feeling. Yeah.
The cyber like a Jew means
grandfather. Okay, Bro. Um,
it is a tough one. See? Yeah. I
can't imagine my Saba growing.
I survived the Holocaust for this.
We'll fill out would you rather
from Christina, but okay. So,
but you're either
retarded your whole life.
Do one bad incident on the Ferris wheel,
but there's funnel cake.
I approved juice and you got to consider
that you might be get way into it and
then want to have that
happen over and over again.
But it's not just a onetime
thing. Sure. I don't,
I don't jerk off to anime porn for
that reason. Why is that? What a five,
I don't want to go down
that road. Right. You know,
and then be like working off the cartoons.
It's too dark or road.
So what you're saying. Yeah. Yeah.
I think I would go with my,
I mean,
is it now or is he still alive?
They're both dead,
but we're assuming they're
still alive. He's alive. Yeah.
Yeah. Take it up as core.
He's old and he's like, let's
go on this. Ferris. Well,
this isn't an interesting distinction
he's making because if it happens to you
in your formative years,
in your youth,
it could do long lasting damage if it
happens. At what age are we talking?
You're a child and this happens.
Are you an adolescent or are
you 40 something year old?
Also if you're an adolescent, if you're,
if you're 17 you're going to come quick.
Sure. But now she's going to
be jerking me off for a while.
Like the guy running it. Like when
you run that back, run that back.
We got to go another
round on the Ferris wheel.
Well that's an interesting
with his fucking hands I hope.
Does their lube lube or is it just
that rough? No, no GRANDPA had rob,
rob, rob, rob. Now here's
what I'm going to do with this one
cause I hadn't considered the age.
I don't want to scar you emotionally too
much so I'm not going to do it to the,
to a child from now on. That's
great. 40 something year old.
You're an adult and your grandfather is
like a couple of years before he dies.
His hands are all decrepit and also
had 40 years of non retarded life.
Go back and become always taught it.
So you'll be born retarded
like of mice and men in
interviews talking about it.
So why did you choose
through a double special?
Interesting. Interesting. They're like,
what's going on with you right now?
I know the,
yeah.
Oh well my grandpa
live the rest of his life retarded.
That'll be crazy. Oh wait,
is it not the rest your life?
Well, that's what I thought.
I had assumed that you'd be born. We'd
go back in time and you're born retarded,
but you got to make choices,
right. It's all right now.
So that's why I think it
might be funnier if from now.
I think it's better though. It's better.
So let's do, let's do it from that.
From now on.
You're retarded from now on you.
That'd be hard to cause I've gotten lead
and then the amount of game I would not
have and your careers destroy it or less.
You'd become the retard it a comedian now.
My intellect wouldn't be
that. All right, the bits,
but here's the thing we can start getting,
do you start getting sympathy tail?
Yeah,
for sure.
How does it still look the same way
people will remember you before you walk
into a bar and then they're like, hey,
I saw you on Netflix and comedy central.
You would get a bunch
of women who would like,
we're already looked to me it was
like whatever, like but not enough.
Yellow is my favorite and
then they're like, Oh wow,
I've had a thing for Atar to people.
Yeah.
Also he was a funny comic wants this
will be good. That's a whole new ones.
A your sex game ticket,
big dive.
You would never think about
pleasing somebody else,
but you've got to also think
I have retard strength. Yeah.
So hard to libido.
Don't forget they are very sexually,
they took off constantly cause they
don't know like you're not supposed to do
this. Like why would you not so good you
guys to try it? Hate mail about that.
Really? She said that and some
someone wrote in, he's like,
I work with in special ed and she's like,
they don't all jerk off all day.
You fucking,
that's because you've done a good job.
They were so mad.
They were pretty upset.
We're going to get some
mail on this one to think,
but it's so worth the hate
mails. Never like, oh just
so you know. Some of them do.
To that, but generally that's like five,
10%. You're, you're off a little bit,
but it's all going fuck you
asked. Thanks. We're not teaching.
Let me ask you this though. Now you're
going to have a decision but go ahead.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay.
Let's just tell us your decision and
then tell us why you chose that. Yeah.
I think I would go with my
grandfather jerking me off. Wow.
I just don't want to be retarded man.
I just don't want retarded and I
fucked some gross people before.
This would be way more damaging,
but I wasn't that close with,
with papa or Saba.
How long do you think it would take you
to finish what it would take? A while.
One time I tried to jerk off in front of
two guys in the La Jolla comedy store,
the Condo.
Um,
I try to work it up like real hard in
the other room and then come out and like
Jews in front of them. Yeah. When I came
out and realize how ridiculous it was.
It was about to come and then it was like,
you got a five more minutes now and I
need to go back for an hour. Go for it.
At the pressure of performance, it
was just like ridiculous and funny.
Were they laughing or were they one
was laughing. One was in horror.
I think I choose the latter. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm going to go grandfather jerking
me off. Wow. It would be rough.
It would take a while. It would
definitely damage me. Um Oh man,
it would definitely,
the thing is that it's going to affect
the rest of your life would have a
definitely a new
relationship with my parents.
I have trouble looking at them,
especially telling them like you have to
tell him one day, you don't want your,
you know what your dad did to me.
This game
should really be called would you
lease rather? Yeah, of course.
Leads us into one of the classic.
Would you rather,
and I know you're not obviously Christian,
but like the biggest a celebratory day
in your house would probably be like
growing up. Would be the celebration.
Oh, you mean like Jewish?
Passover is more like a family
thing. Hanukkah, Hanukkah.
But everyone's together. Passover,
Passover, Rosh Hashanah, passover,
passover. Yeah. So it's Passover.
Everybody gets together.
Oh my God, I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry.
Oh my God was really fucking,
Nah, you can leave the district.
Oh my God, you guys are so disgusting. So
if, uh, you guys have
your, you know, yeah,
you sacrifice your baby,
you do your,
no, the non Jewish babies died.
Right? Okay. So Nikela dog,
you guys do your training.
You say your prayer, um,
you know there's one drop of Jewish, non
Jewish baby blood and that Motsa recipe.
If that's your furniture, one drop.
Don't fuck, it's not a whole baby.
We for sure we killed the
babies and put them out.
But like only one drop is
necessary. You're way off
base. I don't know all of the
things, but you, you do your coin flip.
Everyone sits there and then at the end,
right.
And is there like a big toast
and everything too? Okay,
so there's all this wine.
Then you say to your family,
you go guys,
I gotta show you something and you,
everybody goes from the dining
room to the living room.
I can already picture that. So everybody's
like, oh cool. And they're like,
what is it? Did you, did you shoot a new
show? What, what are you going to show us?
And you go,
just sit here and watch this.
And you put in a DVD and they're
all like waiting in anticipation.
And by the way, pastor,
do you say happy Passover?
Like what are you guys happy wife?
Happy pays off.
Piss off or could Yontif good.
Yontif yeah.
Okay. So that's for all holidays. So
they're all sitting in front of the TV.
You press play,
your onscreen and 10 homeless guys
are standing around you and they go,
hold on, hold on. This
is one of the options.
Of course.
Video of both though. No, no,
no, no. It's one or the other.
Otherwise it's like continuing and
they're getting divorced over it and then
it could be late. Okay, so
let's say it's homeless,
but they're homeless.
Homeless, right? Yes.
And they all masturbate
to completion on you
squirting or no? One that, yeah, cause it
could be like skirt and they're all like,
they're all really loud about it. It's
really uncomfortable watching. Yes.
Wait, everybody, the last one ends,
you turn to camera and you say, uh,
how they pay us off. Yeah. Happy pay,
stuff like that. And then it cuts to
black and you turn back and you're like,
what do you guys think?
It's either that or when you
put the DVD and you press play,
it's just you alone looking at the camera
and you masturbate to completion and
you say happy.
Yeah.
It's the shame that it's either you doing
the thing or having the thing done to
you.
That's shameful.
I mean there's so many different
people in the family, so yeah.
Well my mom and dad was most disappointed
with me versus like I could explain to
the nephews if we're always
just masturbating. My
sisters could be like, okay,
you're going to have to
learn this eventually. Yeah.
What are we was doing
was called masturbation.
You'll do it when you get a little older.
Yeah.
Can we take the children out of the room?
I think the children don't need
to be privy. I'm going to take,
I know what needs to be privy.
Let's change it to just adults.
I don't think it's fair
to put kids in that.
So I'm picturing me when I was growing up,
maybe when I'm like 22 no one
has shown us kids yet. Correct.
Everyone's grown up.
Adults only is what we change it to.
Tom Children shouldn't watch the video,
but it's your mom is your dad.
It's your grandma, grandpa, brother,
sister. They've all, there's no children.
Okay. Looks fine. It's all adults.
Okay. Oh, can I say a problem with us?
You can't use a DVD player on so
I'm like I got to put this a DVD.
Yeah, they'd be like, what are
you talking about? Here it is.
It's a live performance guys.
One of my friends,
they're all going to do this
with me versus all right guys.
And actually the way I got to come to the
backyard and they're all waiting there.
Or originally the way I, I like this
one is to send out a company wide email.
Guys come to my desk at 1230 and everyone
shows up your boss and then you're
like, and then you, that's
a good way to masturbate.
That's a good way to quit his job.
But what would you guys do with
grandfather or retarded? I chose no,
I'd rather grandfather a
hundred percent wow. Yeah. I've,
I've lived a great life. I've had
all but my son, Shit grandfather,
I have to raise my kid but
I feel like it would like,
now that I think about it and talking
about it with you, it would take so long,
so long go somewhere like focus
so intensely on it. You know,
you'd have to block it out.
It's like so hard.
It's a really big about sexual stuff and
if you like at all pop up or if you get
that smell Begay
and every time he's like,
oh throw it. And he's just just, you
know, and it wouldn't be good at it.
It's not like he's a fucking to
lick his hand the way it does.
Okay.
Yeah. I ended up, if
you're like having trouble,
he'd be like going into your balls
and you're like, yes, yes I do.
I need help on my lap like old times.
Yeah.
You want me to do your
balls to your bald man?
Bald? My grandpa, I'm on airy.
So what's it going to be?
A funnel cake?
Yeah.
So jerk off in front of my family or
have 10 girls kind of boot cocky you,
I mean originally it was 10 homeless men,
but I feel like we adapt it for male.
They're really picturing men
and women homeless. Okay.
And they're being board said it had
a whole book. Does it smell? Yeah,
that's what it sounds like.
Oh my God.
This is the front of your face,
like in the back yard.
I mean just
going to watch or be like, Hey, get
off now. Just watch their roads with,
everyone just says watching it.
Just like shock and
so you're really thinking about
the conversation afterwards? Yeah.
Talk us through your thinking.
Okay.
You're thinking about
afterwards how to deal with it.
You're also thinking about if no one
was there, which one? I'd rather like.
I don't want to have homeless
people jizzing on me.
Like it's not just about the reaction.
It's also like this is happening. Right.
Interesting point, but can't you
masturbate in front of your family?
That's another thing. Looking into your
mother's eyes, looking at your sister.
Right, right, right. Oh yeah.
Well I mean like the homeless people
[inaudible] on you and squirting on you.
That could be,
would you rather if the family is not
even involved because it's not even a good
thing. Yeah, but the family
adds a nice leg up for sure.
I'm saying it's a bad thing,
but masturbation without my family
is no big deal without your phone,
but we are family. It adds a whole other
level. That's why it's such an important.
Would you rather, this is
a seminal one, if you will.
I think I know I'll get,
my thinking is I could sort of throw it
off to them as like I was forced to do
this. I wasn't the one doing it. That's
right. Now. That was the law masturbating.
That's right though.
It's a more normal thing,
like obviously you know intellectually
that I do this when you're not around.
Right. And now the hall, man,
I bet it's a shell it that way.
It's a shame displacement.
It's,
it's either the shaming is done to you
or you're responsible for your shame,
so that's I think why it's
psychologically very provocative.
As I'm talking it through,
I might have just switched.
Yeah, I was going to go get,
get just done. Right. But I
think maybe now mastering,
but then I can't, the conversation,
they'd be like, no, you
were doing that. Are you
were masturbating. Why did
you do that? It's past.
We asked you to stop. But we're saying,
hey, please stop. The other way.
It's like we asked the homeless people to
please stop and they did it. All right.
Get away from them, but I'm on
the ground. Yeah, and they have,
they take the responsibility, right.
What's happened? We made him do this. Oh,
they forced me. I mean, I lost a boy.
This is a really on the line with
the goals. When the ever you do it,
would you rather not have
people go, oh yeah. Hey,
it's the dilemma. Yeah. Yeah.
I, I, I think the getting masturbated on,
do you prefer that one before?
I don't really like using that word.
It's your preference.
It's what you find enjoyable.
I think that there would be
that conversation of like,
all right, he masturbated.
Why don't you that in front of us? But
this is like, to what are you into?
That's all. That's what is, was become
ours of our sun. So That's interesting.
The shame of what are your
sexual preferences? Are you into,
this is what our he's into versus
we don't know what our he's into,
but he's masturbating in front of us
and that's in your masturbated in their
house while they were there when
I was an orthodox Jew. Right.
Where you're supposed to not do
that. Oh for sure not. It wasn't,
there was no religion in the world that I
know of except, no. Even that that does,
that allows it. Will you ever bring
stuff like that up in that era?
Would you be like,
I want to masturbate or would they talk
to you about stuff like that? No, no, no.
Even sex ed was having or core or
your folks Orthodox Jewish. They are,
they have gotten to the point where
if we're out and my dad's like,
if you want to get a burger,
you can get a burger. Oh really?
But that like took a lot. How,
how are they with your success?
Like I like my success. They don't
like the way I've achieved it. Uh,
like when I took my dick out on, on HBO,
my mom's like, why do you have to tell?
I told people to watch we're going
to be on TV. Why? And I'm like, mom,
you shouldn't watch this stuff.
It's, it's exactly not for you. Well,
they watch the special. Oh
yeah, they will. Yeah. Geez.
I got comedy central before they got
cable just so they could watch me. Really?
Yeah, they're proud of
me. I asked my aunt once,
I was doing some joke about like herpes
at the DC Improv and they were there and
then they left right afterwards
when I was like, what did they,
how did they feel about that?
She goes,
I think they just assumed you were joking
about like the setup and this payoff.
Oh, that it's all made up. Yeah. That's
good. I'm joking about having it though.
Not having it a fucking, excuse me.
Making love to a woman. Sorry Christina.
I love to a woman who had herpes. Oh. And
they were like, oh, there's just like,
it's amazing how many people
like, well, they're like,
and so you just made that
whole thing up, right? No,
I just chose the funniest way to say it.
The amazing one to me is when the,
when people think you made up like a,
a super detailed story, like a story
that people give their like, so you may,
like I had a story about meeting
Mike Tyson and they were like,
you made all that up. He just made that
up. We really created if he could do that.
I mean, you kind of want to be
like, yeah, I think I'm creative,
but like you think I'm mean, I made up
all the beats of like converse. Like why
would I make that? Yeah. But I
guess if they, if you don't do it,
then you just assume now don't let them
see behind the curtain. And guys, come on.
I know, but it's just weird that
like that a plant you're like, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Now does your mom do that
thing where she, when she gets her period,
she goes to the water. The
Jacuzzi? Yeah. I like that a lot.
My mom hasn't gotten her period
since before Obama for sure.
Probably back in the day.
40 almost of natural water. Uh, that's an
a measurement of natural water you need.
Okay. After you have your period, you
need seven clean days. So no spotting.
No nothing. Count to like popcorn when
it pops and you're like three seconds,
you go want to pop. Okay, start
again. One, two, three Oh one, two.
You know what? So you've got seven clean
days. No spotting everything he got.
Spot starts over. When you get
seven clean days, then yeah,
go to the Mikvah ritual bath.
You could also use a lake or ocean
because it's got plenty of water in their
natural water, but not like a pool.
It's got to be like a natural,
it's gotta be rainwater coming up.
I always think about whenever I hear these
things like that, it's crazy, right? No,
just the amount of effort, just
effort. I guess we're all, well,
let me tell you this. In terms of like
what you said, like a practicality. Yeah.
So period, let's say three, five days,
but they had spotting
dead seven clean days.
Now Your Day 12 then the next day you
go to the Mikvah 13 and now you're,
you haven't fucked your husband in 1314
days tenure and you're at your most
fertile. Yeah, it's great. It's
actually a way of making sure
and also keeps you like, yeah. I think
also like just relationship wise you go,
he's got no road. So it's like
when you're apart from each other,
when you come back you're
like, oh, I can't wait to see
you again. Yeah, it's true.
Versus you've seen a lot of couples. You
should. I do. I liked what the Jews do.
Good Shit.
Yeah.
But what are you Orthodox
Jew symbolically anymore?
Like did you do anything masturbate in
front of your family? Some of the foods,
I still get off on that
because I grew up with it.
But if I'm home I'll sing their
songs with them. You know,
that just sounds really at this
point. But do they, is everybody,
here's the other thing, how, how
are they as far as they have,
they accepted your zip up.
My Dad wants in a while,
says he's from coming to shoulder mild,
you know, come with and I was like, no,
I feel bad. Last time I went home. So
you would say the grace after meals? Um,
there's this, if you have three or more
men above 13 as an extra prayer say,
and one person says that everyone like
joins in. So you say like it's in Hebrew,
but you say like bless it other for
giving us food and then it was like, yeah,
for real though. And then he's like,
thanks for all these people here.
I was like two totally. Yeah, it's just
a back and forth a little bit. Yeah.
My Dad is like, you want to, you want
to lead this one? And I was like, oh no,
I don't, I don't remember this. And
he's like, no, you read another book.
And I was like, oh my mom's like,
we do it. And I'm like, ah, ah.
But then as soon as they
did and I was like, what the
fuck is wrong with me? Yeah,
just not converting.
If I could have done it,
if I was at a Buddhist thing and
they said, can you read this thing?
I would have done it.
Yeah.
So it's like Beth because it's
family and children, but I mean like,
I feel bad about it. Yeah,
I understand. What, back to
the fucking question at hand.
Yeah. It hasn't chosen. Sorry.
It's so hard. Just think, no,
I don't.
I've never had somebody.
It's the before and it's a door it
and it's the afternoon, the afternoon,
the drawing explaining to them, it's
like, of course they master it. It's like,
why don't you do that already? Why
is masturbation so, so taboo? Yes,
it is. For you. Your House,
it's not a normal thing. It's
not a natural occurrence.
Meaning that's the double thing of you
having Orthodox parents is that that's
off the table. Discussion wise,
why trust. Parents were like,
why are you doing that outside?
Right.
What's your choice?
What is it?
I think it's the homeless
people. Yeah. Yeah. No,
I think I chose, the other one I show is
doing it myself. He's got good parents.
I could tell them afterwards, the halls,
people like I wasn't into that. Right,
right, right, right. No, I understood.
I mean I, I, I got it. I just, I,
so I rejected all the other column.
I displaced the shame.
I prefer to put the shame on the
other people. What if want to be
to them. This is the, Oh
gee, would you rather, wow.
It's great when you come
across a good one. You're like,
I gotta remember this for next time.
Oh this one is like from, yeah,
this is like a six or seven year old
one. Yeah. I have one for you. For me.
You could do this to Eric.
Okay. Tommy, would you rather,
would you rather have your
mouth smell like fiefs FIFA,
Theo or dog? Her blind dog
smells like food. Is it
the other one I look at you.
Oh you don't want him to like it.
The halibut fucking, it's
horrible. Yeah. Okay.
So would you have either your mouth
smells like feet or my mouth smells like
fiefs yours. Why? What? Really? Yeah,
but then you have to live with me and I
have a, I'll have a garbage mouth. Yeah,
I know you just have you. I just kiss
other parts, you know, just ruined her.
Her feelings. The woman you love like
this will be easier for you. Right?
But easier for me to have your dog.
You don't have to smell his horrible.
Now how bad smelling mouth anyways,
cause Dad's get dad mouth.
You're going to have dad mouth
and like when you're 50 right?
Don't dad's mouth smell like shit.
Like older guys
smells like the deodorant they were
putting on and they, and they look like,
like older guys mouth looked
like they were just decomposing.
Like you look at your mouth, you're
like, you look like a fucking,
it's like a corpse already. See, I feel
like it'd be, I'd be like, get it anyway.
I think we would get to the point, I'd
be like, you know how your mouth is.
So you would be like, Hey,
can I get a kiss? I'd be like,
Hey, your cheek. You know,
like kiss you over
there smells horrendous.
You wouldn't be able to sleep next to me.
Like I couldn't sleep with my head next
year. Head on the pillow, bedrooms.
I would just know. I'd just be like
face the other way, you know? You know,
you know you face your wall. Yeah.
I would have used smell like fiefs.
I would have the mask. Yeah. Yeah.
The other person has it fucking
day of my life. I want your life.
I would be talking to people and you
could, I mean if they had like my dogs,
if I had my dog's breath, I know
people would be like, oof Jesus man.
You want a mint? Normally strong enough.
You wouldn't be able to do anything.
I have a serious one for you guys.
Serious was wrong. Would you rather
never do stand up ever again or split up?
Oh God,
God. Cause I mean I put a lot
of people don't know comedians.
This is who we are at the core.
So like split up but just did divorce.
But we can still see each other like
split up meaning or you're done.
You're nice to each other. They'd be fuck
once a year. Yeah, we split the custody.
How's things going with you? Like
when you drop them off, the kids fine.
Sees both the parents.
You guys are both amicable.
I mean that would suck, but I'd have
to, I want our family be together.
I don't want my kid to grow up the way
I did is terrible. It's fine. It's fine.
It doesn't seem that bad.
It's not good. Split up.
But why? Well, here's the thing, you make,
you make a good living doing stand up.
You would really have to find another,
I mean the podcast is great too,
but that would really ruin your
livelihood and our livelihood jewelry.
You know what I'm saying?
We are split up a white diamonds.
Of course. I got it for
yesterday. Really Birthday.
I didn't know when your birthday was
coming. No one cares about in February.
Where do you want to go on
this trip? Oh yeah. Oh yeah,
I bet the bet. Yeah, I heard you
guys talking about your trip.
Well I pes
thank,
thank you is mine. I bought
it. It's hers now. Beautiful.
There's tasting. Julie's
amazing washed up. Fuck man.
So I talked to Bart Crysler
and the the the re obese.
Yeah. Bark Chrysler. Yeah. So what
is your opinion on his weight gain?
Has His uh, man, I don't know.
I was trying to spin the cause even when
he took his shirt off for that thing
and wait himself as not obese,
he still looks obese as fuck.
You mean at the actual way?
January 3rd I guess that's what it was.
That you saw him, you saw him with
me a few days ago. What'd you think?
He looked like? He looked, boy, he didn't
look like a fucking workout guy. Right.
But he said he definitely cut
weight for the way in. Right. Well we
both call water worse, but like there's,
you put the water back on and it's barely,
it's nice.
His face doesn't look much
different than he did way before.
His belly is just so gross.
And like we were talking,
we saw on the back it's pushed out
where it's a hard, if he lost weight,
you should have that fold that fold over.
Yeah. Thing a little bit. A little bit.
Right. Do you feel like,
cause he was saying,
I mean I'd like to get them back
on a scale. Maybe I will during a,
is it going a skank fest? I don't
know where he's going. He's,
he's on the road a lot. Um, if you,
if you were to describe
a, he said that, uh,
he was really upset that
people were saying he gained
the weight back. Yeah. Well,
he's, no, what he's upset about is that
he came in the white pack. Right. I Dunno.
Maybe. And I was like,
well, you know, he goes,
I have no,
here's what he said.
Yeah, it's a lot. And I
go, dude. And he goes,
I heard you say you did tell me there
was like just fucking Tom who's starting
up again. That'll get the book. Yeah. And
people have been tweeting him. Really?
Yeah. Like why did you get fat again?
Let's get him on a scale again. Yeah. Um,
but I don't know, you saw him,
at least for our audience,
for me to tell the difference between
two 20 and two 40. Yeah. You know,
he's a tall guy. You would
understand that. But he's a tall guy.
He's over six feet tall, well over six
feet tall. Well over six one you know,
well into the six six feats. I
think he's just under six one. Ah,
you're just under six feet. But he's
well over six feet. That's a liar.
I can't believe.
I can't believe after asking
for the fucking measurement
when you were well over
an inch short of, and you
said you're worth, there was
no, I said I was six feet.
You said you were six one I
didn't say six one one one.
He said he was 61 which turned
out to be also not true. Yes.
So then they had to do new BMS. Yes. But
you guys both may have made it anyway,
but that being said, he is fat ago. Sorry.
He's obese again. Yeah. Don't know.
Don't know.
Just look at him.
I mean he's not doing anything that he's
supposed to be doing to lose the weight,
but he managed to before,
I don't know how he did it before.
It talks to people who only cram for
tests and still manage to get A's. Yeah.
This isn't the way it's gonna
work, but he does. His version is,
it's the Mickey Mantle Gene.
Mickey Mantle on. Yeah.
That was really funny about that bat
was the phrasing of it, where you go,
what was it? It was just cute out
of obesity. Just get out of it.
That's all you have to do. Just don't
be OPB overweight. The overweight,
just don't be a medically
obese. And by the way, the lack,
the lack of faith in either of us was
also hilarious because he was like,
only one or you can do it. I don't
think your book do it in a way. Yeah.
It's like if you really did have a good
workout, I was like, yeah, for sure.
But I didn't think either one of them.
Can I ask you one thing? It's so dumb
and it's like such a minor dumb question,
but I've been thinking about it.
There is a time during their weigh ins
were Joe called you and you were abroad
and he kept calling you and calling you.
And like
I was a, I was out with Comedians in New
York. We're out eating trust Korea. I was,
I left the next day.
Why did you not just answer the phone
like you kept answering and then you'd
hang up?
Oh,
it's because of this,
because I have this new feature on my
phone that it just a, if I moved slightly,
it'll just answering my pocket.
Oh Wow.
This whole time I'm like,
why would I do that?
I can understand why you
would do that to somebody.
Yeah. It was a day before I left
was the first way. And, and I,
and I waited till I guess midway through
that second podcast. That's why I left.
So weird. Yeah. That's all it
was. And then when I finally
saw it was like, oh, what?
I was kinda drunk with the guys.
Okay. And uh, I'm like, what a jerk.
Why don't you just pick up the phone?
And that was hitting me with it too.
It's like, let me show you
the way ads. Here's what
number. I was like, wait, wait,
I don't, I need to know what the BMS
like what are they have to beat down.
Slow down. You got word that that we were
basically whatever add it or near it.
What you like.
Fuck.
Like did you feel a little bit also fun
but also like I'm all about competition.
Yeah. So I'm like, I want
the exact measurement. Yeah,
you're just like the easily
did it. I'm like man, cause
slow down. Slow down. Yeah,
we do have the have you. You got it.
Bye Bye. The way after your new weight,
your new height of five something
unbelievable. Unbelievable. This guy.
Yeah.
You were 0.15 of an inch above obese.
If you were 0.1 5.15,
if you were,
if you were five 11.7 instead of five
11.85, you would be about obese. Yes.
So for the next day it's like, hey man,
if he gains, I'll pound back. Yeah,
I win the bet. So I'm so I'll say like,
let me see the fucking competition.
Oh my goodness. I have never strict
on a goddamn single bedroom, my life.
So what are we going to do though? What
should we do? Let's do something. Uh,
August the iron man I'm through. I have
a pretty good busy fall. That's my whole,
let me ask you a question, but
what about in November? Me,
n n Burt will be in New Orleans to go
on that joker's crews we'll be launching
from there. Yeah. So maybe something
is November football season.
I'll say it again. What do you
like be fun? Um, nobody really,
you know what would be right. We have to
put it off obviously a little bit. Yeah.
Would be in probably end of January.
Yeah. I don't even know where it is.
I look it up. Yeah. Uh, the
national championship game,
that'd be fun to go to basketball.
No, wait, what'd we call it? Football.
College football. Yeah. That'd be good if
you're a huge college football fan. Yeah.
Okay. That'd be fine. It's
always on a Monday and the
Oh, right. That's great. Yeah.
Okay. Let's do it. We could
do that. Was your team at Fsu,
they have no chance next year or they
do, no, I mean a, there'd be there,
they're going to be a pre season top
10. Yeah. So there's a chance. Yeah,
there's a chance, but
either way, be quiet.
They also opened the season against
Alabama. That'd be their show.
They'll get there. They'll
get a pretty good, uh,
the jump up if they win that and they
still have it. Oh yeah. When that, yeah.
They'll, that'd be the talk station. Yeah.
Yeah. Um, yeah, that'd be good. I didn't,
I liked the idea of going to a, to
um, Barcelona, I'll be honest to you.
That was rooted in truth.
I also knew how,
how retarded it kind of went off.
But then when it was like,
actually like when we were
like, Hey, let's do it. I was
like that'll be super fun.
Super Fun. Yeah. I'll stay in like
a big like an airbnb together.
I thought that'd be fine
or folly cause they were playing the end
of the games ended up being like crazy
good game. Oh really? One of the, uh,
one of them was I think one of them,
well there was a big shocker cause I guess
they have, they had multiple, you know.
Yeah. Yeah. So there
was one big upset or um,
I think Paris beat Barcelona but no
one was expecting on the first one.
And I think there's a game after that
were Barcelona went messy play for
Barcelona you guys. Yeah. Yeah.
Wow. Yeah that would have been fun.
It would have been fun man.
But anyways, by the way,
I had my plan set up cause you're like,
oh I fly first class and I'm like,
you know what, it is
your flight. That's fine.
And I was already had a set like you're
flying first class and Bert and I are in
the back
by the way.
I know they would have harassed me
the entire flight bird. Oh yeah.
He would have been like
to be told you can't be up here. And he
would have been so upset to be in coach.
So upset plus the middle seat.
I was going to get him. Oh God.
It's the worst.
Yeah we have to do,
we'll have to do some national
championship game would be pretty,
we look it up just saying. Yeah. Let
me see where it's got a lovely, okay.
Is that soccer? Yeah. Jesus Christ.
Fucking now definitely split up.
That would be a cool one for sure.
And then I could finally stop
getting comments on all my fucking,
everything I post, I
call me a Welsh. Yeah,
it's an upcoming game. It will be
played in Atlanta. Atlanta. Yup.
January 8th hey,
can we go to the vortex and get that
peanut butter Banana Burger? Absolutely.
Annotate a new stadium. A new state of the
art. I'm really billion dollar stadium.
Yeah. Fuck yeah. That can
be fun. Okay. What is it?
January 31st January 8th January 8th
yeah. Is it cold? That seems way early.
No, no, no, that's right. They
do the New Year's eve stuff
in Atlanta. It gets, it gets cold but not
that cold. It'll be fine to go to, well,
it's very jackets. Do you want to go want
to do that? Yeah, that could be a thing.
Yeah. Let's do it. I'll, I'll, I'll not
scheduling anything ahead of time now.
All right.
We'll probably go for like the weekend.
You got to go for a couple of days.
Yeah.
You don't want to just land and go to
the national championship game, but yeah,
we'll go for this. Even go Sunday
and then stay Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday something. Yeah.
Oh, too bad it's there.
Cause we could be like go
fishing or whatever. We can
figure it out so much. Okay.
Hell yeah, that'd be great. Okay.
I hope I kill myself before that so
I don't have to actually pay it off.
So, uh, I might have to get two seats
for Bert if he keeps going at this rate.
That's totally true. So enormous. I
wonder if it's just that, you know,
we always see him shirtless. We never
see him. That was my theory, by the way,
when those, true, when he told me, he
goes, when he said like everyone's saying,
I gained all this weight back. I go, dude,
every place you go you
don't have a shirt on. Yeah.
Most people not even like forget obese,
like the average person shirtless.
It isn't like, wow, you look great.
You know, what can I tell you what,
maybe a retort to that?
Yeah.
I took my shirt off constantly around
Manhattan or anywhere that's shorts off
for sure. Suns out, guns
out, you know? Yeah. And uh,
when I had my shirt off, especially after
I got back, people are like, Oh man,
you're so thin, Andrew. Lose weight.
Right. And with him, they're signs.
Did you gain weight? It's just cause the
baseline product isn't good. Right, right,
right. How right. So like
no, same way as before,
but I will say this,
I will say this,
if I walked around all the time shirtless.
Yeah.
It's not going to be compliments men.
No, it's not going to be like, yeah,
no one's going to, but like most
people have the sense minus him.
Wonder how much that weighs. I want
to, I want to get a scale. What do you,
what would your guess be if you had
to guess? Right now? I don't know.
Two 93 95 I don't think it's three
she's like, is that's gotta be off
by like 10 pounds. I don't know, man.
It's gotta be like two 78 to 84 real.
Even if, forget the way back. He's
not above two 40 yeah, but yeah,
I think to 20 yeah, no to 22 and
you add two to 19 the well, the,
the final day I was two 16 and he
was two 20 I think. Yeah. Yeah.
I would have loved if I want to hop back
and it the BMI and rugged and have to
go, oh fuck the boost and
boost seven grants per calorie.
That's really hard to lose weight
and drink. Whenever I see a woman,
especially in the comedy scene and
suddenly it's like when I'm seeing them in
six months and it's like, hey you
look great. Like what has been doing,
it's 90% of the time stopped
drinking. Absolutely. That's
the one thing you can't,
you can't do both man.
You can't lose weight.
I was gaining weight when I was traveling
for the first month and I was like,
am I getting [inaudible]
this isn't making sense.
I mean you're like no processed
foods. I'm active as fuck. Yeah.
And then my friend was like
Chang wait drinking beers
like 20 ounces for like a dollar.
Everyone is a psycho though where
he will go like you know if you,
if you go on his Instagram
it's like every night he's like
40 people and then the next day he
goes and he runs. He does. Yeah. Oh,
so Hayden, the gates, the damage,
he does that self regulating
thing where he's like,
recall the four in the morning and
you're running all over five miles. We,
you crazy. You can't emphasize
your liver though. Yeah.
No Sim two years from now.
God, he was so great. Yeah.
Was a good guy.
It's kind of at least she have a living
memorial for him living funeral. He goes,
thanks.
So we can really
feel his friends come
out. Yeah, we should have,
we should do that before his heart attack.
What?
It's like how to live in more than
in Atlanta, but book them for a show.
You want to do this show
and then when he shows up,
just have like the big photo on
that. You know what I mean? Yeah.
The flowers underneath it.
Yeah. Oh, that would be great.
And have people just to have say
some words, music playing. Yeah.
It's the intervention. Is that it?
Yeah, he'd be, he'd be like, you know,
this is a real fucking bummer.
He'd be so upset for us to map.
It's too real though. It's
too close. Yeah. Reality. Um,
did you ever have like a horrible
office corporate job? Yeah. Yeah.
It's up to the health network.
Do you guys ever do like cool from
stuff getting to know each other?
No.
Look at the people fairly copic.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
So everybody's doing this.
Wow. All girls by the way.
Well a guy wrote in that he had,
he had to do one of these and he wrote in
that uh, he was like, my name is Kevin.
Yeah.
And I killed a man and if you really do
all whole thing stopped cause he was in
Afghanistan.
Yeah.
And but his like the first thing
that came to mind was I killed a man.
He said this is big for him as well.
But like everyone stop and they were like,
well we got broke through the ice.
Yeah.
Somebody sent a taboo.
A new one of these in no
fucking dumb white people.
Shit.
I hope he does a flip
and lands on his head.
I can blow my brains out
a Walmart.
Oh my God. I mean, and then
it's like, then he like says
we are,
we
are,
we are Walmart
jeans.
You're going to be a cashier. Wow. Yeah.
Exact for the fucking endorsement.
Old Dad outfit. By the way,
we've got the died jeans tucked
in shirt and the Denver shoes.
Those Denver,
a rugged sneaks.
See people wearing really good luck.
I'm playing with my daughter on,
what did [inaudible] say?
1,000 of of something.
Oh yeah, yeah. Oh right.
I blocked down this guy.
They've all got jeans on Lincoln.
This door here when his
white sneakers and dad jeans.
You think the one next to that guy to
his right? Uh, Sudhakar. Yeah, no. Yeah.
That one. No, the car off the wall.
The lady. Yeah. Do you think, uh,
things just like the office,
like slut, she's a hot,
people have hooked up with
our, and it's a drama. Oh yeah.
Oh, this is so awful. I said,
look at locker. Oh look
how, oh my gosh. One burst
I'd kill myself was so I think you
should go. We a and then you use here.
Let's just say that's what I was doing.
He did manage to make a verse that's,
that held the cadence and everything.
Yeah.
Yeah. Cashier something good. You know,
it's a bummer it's on,
but another marketing song from a
convention for 10 minutes
showing you things you like.
Case Mag photos from
my cat.
Not kids someday
in Sweden too.
You helped me.
Great Boys. Miss that
gets better. Listen to
me, the staff.
Wow. My cat. My kids. Yeah, you got it.
Social. That guy does not have the shops.
He wrote that song. Oh really? Yeah. Yeah.
He's the old or Milli Vanilli. Oh, shawl.
The bomber. I was going to say about
that Walmart one. Yeah. It's like, look,
you take a job at Walmart,
at least I would for the chill
factor like there was no,
not a lot of heavy responsibility.
You clock in, you clock out,
you don't have no one's
fucking watching you,
and then to have to suffer
through that corporate nonsense.
It takes a whole fun out of working
there in the first place. I would
love to that point. I would love to see
the end of that video when he's like,
Whoa, we have a class, and
somebody goes, hey man, I quit.
He put your name tag down and walk
out. Yes. The guy that goes like,
I don't want to see in these fucking
songs. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sucks enough to work here. Splice that up.
Yeah. With that song over his like, dude,
I don't want to do this. Radhika I want
your manager. You don't do what I want.
I really enthusiastic thing.
I'm going to be a cashier one day.
All right. Better in terms of like letting
you know, because it should have been,
if it was the real song, this
should be like two more verses. Yes.
He let you know what the
handoff that this song was over.
He did a way better job in
the Groundlings. Do. Yeah.
It's what you like indigo
spending. That's true. He
knew there was a, there
was a time limit. Yeah.
Yup.
That was for sure.
Yeah.
Why does that go together?
So that was really good.
Thank you very much.
So much.
So what, how, why would he
not? No, he does not sound good
on that. Yeah. Social. Yeah.
Very Jesus. I'm trying to think. I had a,
I used to work at a company
called world link. Yeah.
That's sold airtime for infomercials.
It was really bad.
Nine to five and I remember they used
to just have us come in and on quarterly
meetings and then they would go over the
earnings and then we'd have to clap at
the earnings and you'd be like,
yeah, but I'm making $5 an hour.
I'm clapping for the fucking CEO. 68
million in profit. That's awesome man.
That's awesome.
But that was great when they didn't have
these demeaning Shibuya is in session.
Yeah.
Shibuya we had icebreakers,
but that was like in like dorm jobs.
Social. I hate situations
where they go, where'd it go?
Around the room and say your name
and like I said in post production,
like where you get the whole team together
and like go around. You'd be like Tom,
post coordinator. Hi. And w w look,
what's your favorite thing to do?
It's really just unduly punishes
the introverts I had. Yeah.
I took an acting class in college and we
had to go around doing the same thing.
You split up into twos and then do
something interesting about yourself,
where you're from,
and then you reported in the other person.
So I was like to the person, the woman
who was interviewing me, I was like,
I don't want to say, I'm just gonna make
something up. It's like, yeah, sure,
whatever.
So I said that I wanted the prices right
and I bid $1 and then there were still
working on it go and he bid
$2 and he ended up winning.
And there were two football players
in the class. Yeah, it was an easy a.
And so the lady said interviewed
me, it was like, okay,
Ari's wants on the price is right.
And he bid $1 and then the guy after him
at $2 a one and the full, I was like,
man, that's bullshit. That was me, a bad
mother fucker. You know, I was trying to,
do you know what I was trying to do? Oh my
God. I was like, well, I mean it's fake,
but the rules would you shouldn't
be doing with $1 with is still,
people have to go. Yeah. Wow. He was
so worked up for me. Black Guy. Yup.
Yeah. Sounds like it
sounds good. Pressure free.
Someone that Danny aquit sang
too. Oh yeah. Hey Hitler.
Hey black guy in my acting class.
It's got some lips.
So you remember a caper?
Uh, the guy that did, uh,
your mom's house song? I don't know. We've
got a lot of songs, but he did it like,
like an actual real song about, he did
another one, but he shot like a video.
Oh my God. Let's see it. So it's
all
going back to your mom,
your mom's house podcast,
like your mom's house,
mom's house.
Go back to your mom's house.
All the lingo name. What's your pronouns?
I'm just asking. I'm just smashing them.
Trying to eat. Got, damn. If they call me,
just stay
on the track.
Go Walk Shit on your thing.
Use the bathroom at your mom's had
to hold my hand and take a shit.
Hold up.
I got something to say.
Hey Jean,
show me how those big seats
running shit like my Bristol stool chart.
No sentence diamonds on the crevice
of you puts you over your denim.
I met your and didn't see, Oh,
when the handicapped stall,
this was she asking you if I had me come
back to your mom's house,
going back to your moms,
going back to your mom's house.
He's laughing the whole time.
I like that
rock and a bottle of
features. Your mom's house,
I'll call you from the party. Ben Talking
Shit. We'll listen to mommy music.
Cool stuff.
My Dad's boat,
we're talking [inaudible] blocker
girls had the pet or I got a bad buy.
She never on the comm.
We thought
a couple of triple d sloughs from
my pronouns.
I said, I got a question. Want to
ask was you read the be retarded.
Get jerked by your grandpa.
Wow.
Going back to your
mom's house,
to your mom's house,
going back to your mom's house,
your mom's house.
The whistles. I love that. Oh,
dad reads ahead of time. He did like
to go to the Amazon link and fun. Yeah,
he wrote us a note. I wrote a little
song, made a video. Hope you like it.
Had a blast recording, fill
name, writing, editing it.
I hope it makes it on the show.
I left the third verse open for
the Mommy Rappers to rap on.
I love the podcast.
Let me know if you have any questions.
Keep those jeans high and tight. Thanks
for the last bird is fat again Sarah.
That's the new mantra. Burdis fat again.
That's going to be the next mayor.
Thank you so much. Caper. That was
make his last name Ferrigan. Yeah,
birth fat again for fat again.
That's great. Wow. Yeah they are.
I have a question for you.
Hold on.
You know how when you go to Fart but
you shit and it's called a chart.
But what about when you go to take a shit
and you only fart? What's that called?
Not a fit. A fit. That's a good
one. We haven't heard that one.
Is it a what? A thump. Fart dub. Yeah.
How does that happen to you guys? A lot.
It's happening. Do you want to have,
there's new submissions this week
cause there was some submitted.
I liked to imposter or
charlatan. By the way, somebody,
this is a new one.
Are you ready for this?
Someone said if you feel a ship but
only for it, you had yourself a fit.
Someone says that. Perfect. Perfect
one says it's the gene pool.
Uh, we call it a Makana. Hey,
due to failure to launch. Oh Wow.
I like that. And this one's
great. Jack route try area.
Oh favorite. That's really good. I think
it's try area two weeks of submission.
That is try Rhea. Rhea. I liked imposter.
Charlatan and Tririga and boosters.
Really funny. God Damn her water bowl.
A water bowl for you. Got To get
yourself a dog. I really want to go out.
It's like how am I going to
do when I go to the road? No,
no, no. Oh you, you leave.
You don't, don't send them to a Kennel. I
have a guy on the east side. Do you live?
Oh, but you're in New York
exclusively now. Yeah.
There's people that you can take
them to. It's normal. Yeah. Oh,
we'll talk fart mistress concept for you.
Oh, number. Cause you're going to do so.
Here's the thing we were talking
about is that I should be,
I should have been doing fart videos
when we were poor in 2008 I easily could
have done it and I was thinking of Fart.
Fart,
mistress.com oh no, you
just fart. Dishonest. Sorry.
Porn. You just fart. Like be
like this lady. Easy, easy head.
Yeah.
There's a reason
like $300
right there. What do you mean
puts it on our website? Yeah.
You guys pay Webcam stuff. Money
for nothing. Checks for free. Yeah,
I do that anyway. Wow.
I mean I, wow. Yeah.
That's a great way to earn extra cash
and the guys want to see girls do it,
do it in any way doing it anyway at home.
I have the perfect scenario
for make to make you,
for your public Queen Atripla debut.
You need to find the longest escalator
or moving sidewalks and I can,
I try to go the whole way.
I think what they're saying far
past people to get their reactions.
I did this before at a Disney world in
man manhole, Florida to several
groups of unsuspecting mommy's.
I would pay to watch this.
Oh my God. It's got farts.
Shame and discuss all the
making of early retirement.
You do the math by mommy.
Thanks. Jeans. Ethan mistress.
We'll consider this submission. Yup. Yeah.
I farted a check it over. Try or you,
I'm sorry.
You like to read
the next sentence in the fucking story.
He's like a monster.
It is easy money.
Why wouldn't you do it? You should do
it. It's weird to sexual though, right?
It's supposed to be fetish.
Yeah.
I think you guys are onto something with
this fart mistress idea. A couple ideas.
I had my be fart.
Mistress 40 gets pulled over
and has to fart her way out of
a, we should write some
fart fart. Like long form.
Is fart mistress pregnant or just gassy?
A trip to the doctor and
fart mistress meets big foot.
You'll never guess what happens next.
Thanks for taking the time to read this.
I wish you luck in your
fart MREs endeavors. Best
regards gains the butt plug,
kind of sore. J D hey, have
you ever gotten a colonoscopy?
It's supposed to, yeah. I'm so, I got
one to look at those fucking hemorrhoids.
Yeah,
they blow air into your rectum so it's
like wide open and then they look at
whatever they got to look at and then
afterwards you just full of air so you
feel like you have to ship,
you don't and then you fart
for about two straight days.
Really just farting out
air but crazy farm raise.
You should charge for your next one and
have like a live feed of that fart and
people can pay to watch and it's not
about it. I went straight to him,
they actually right from there and I'm
just like, I had to lie on the ground.
Just fart the whole time. See
you capitalized. Oh thank God
that I have drank a full glass of
water and this full bottle of Fiji.
You guys have not even come close.
Well I mean constantly.
I mean I had that and I this
coffee, nothing like another one.
Anyway,
last time
I done been done for a minute,
man.
It was the current champion.
I am. Oh really? Please.
I'm also the observation champ, but
that's another thing we'll go into later.
We're going to do,
we're going to wrap this up.
Just let people know again,
the special is coming out double negative
children and adulthood on Netflix.
July, July one eight, July one eight.
Um, and then are you working on,
are you already working on
building your next night?
My next special is gonna be all
about Judaism. I've decided, yeah,
I'm going to truly try to like
flush that out and exercise it.
Are you going to do it like in a Collin
way where it's like a almost like one
man show.
It's not going to look at it.
I mean I have that to couple
of years in Edinburgh,
so I really sort of like been
influenced by those one man.
That's like fee and type shows,
but um,
workout or clubs and like make
it like funny, like American
stand up. Yeah. Um, uh,
that all you want. But like, uh,
yeah, column would be a good one.
The Way Neil Brennan did three mikes.
It's interesting.
I'll watch a lot of stuff like that
and see how I'll figure out a mixture
between like the stories laws and
like tradition. Great. Awesome man.
Yeah, I've got about like 20
now. It's pretty shitty early on,
but I mean you just started,
you know, it'll get there.
What's the name of the new special? Say it
again? Double negative. Double negative.
It's a double feature
to double feature album.
Will it play as one you'll play as to
one stops the next little just like
automatically start playing.
I was like a new episode starts or if
you just watch one and then leave the 45
and 45 so they're like manageable
amounts of time. Smart to do.
Not 60 60 smart. I think so, yeah.
Also it was too hard to get a crowd to
like really be in for an hour. Yeah. Yeah.
Talking about this for not for two
hours, I mean, yeah, for comedy.
Yeah. And then if you don't play it on
Netflix, would you come back and be like,
do you want to resume playing?
You know,
just like any stop watching house of
cards. Do you want to presume that?
Do you want to resume ours refers
double negative house of cards.
I heard of it.
Coach farts a foreign so sorry,
are you into the new season? I
stopped the first year. Oh you did?
I couldn't get over and talking to me.
You just seem like I really enjoy it.
Yeah, no, it was good when I watched
it. I actually liked it. I just,
we're working to try like
seven episodes in total.
No, no, no. To the new season.
Yes. All right. We got to go.
Thank you guys for listening to the
show. Thanks for having me, you guys.
It's been a while since I've been on
here long. Two houses ago or something.
A long time. Yeah. I think I was on
this podcast in three different places.
Red Bands in the department. That's
right. Your, your your beach house.
Yeah. Yeah. Redondo and uh,
yeah. Here and silver lake.
Maybe silver, like Silver Lake House.
We had Ethiopian food wafting
through because our neighbor was,
we shared walls right next to that
hey place, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cool. And the back. It's fine.
That was a good time. All right.
All Times or good times. Are you
going to be on the road at all or no?
Or I'll be in Montreal. No, I'll be in
Montreal. The nasty job hosting that show.
Big j Robert Kelly Godfrey,
Jimmy Carr. It's a good show. Yeah. That's
a really good show. Yeah, I'm going to,
okay. Sweet. All right. I'll see you guys.
Thanks for listening. Lots of love. Yeah.
I love you mommies.
Thanks.
Talking to,
you're
talking to your
fellow.
I was
talking to
a
five but five, five, five.
Yeah.